ALL RIGHT IS IN GERMAN AND WE
WELCOME YOU TO THE THURSDAY
EDITION OF THE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE WE WELCOME
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU. HI
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN HERE WITH
THE COMMITTEE WERE GONNA START
AS A SUB TODAY ONCE WE HAVE
INDIVIDUALS THAT- MY GRADE AND
WE WILL BE ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM. WE HAVE NINE BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA EIGHT BILLS WILL
BE ON THE REGULAR FILE ONE
BILL- IF YOU FIFTY FIVE WILL BE
HEARING FROM CENTER STERN- ON
TESTIMONY ONLY TODAY. I WE'RE
GONNA BE ASKING WE'RE GONNA BE
TAKING SENATOR BACKERS ITEM
FIRST- THERE ARE NO CONSENT
ITEMS HERE TWO DAYS WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE US IN A RECORD TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD AND AS HE
DOES WE'RE GONNA STOP PUSH A
QUORUM- MISTER NOW CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
MCGUIRE HERE MCGUIRE PRESIDENT
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN
PRESIDENT SENATOR DORADO RAZA
PRESENT YOU HAVE A QUORUM THE
QUORUM IS IN THE STATUS OF THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
WELCOME THE VICE CHAIR AND I
CENTER DRAWS AND I WERE JUST
SHARING BABY STORIES IN HEARING
ABOUT. THE YEARBOOK AD THAT SHE
PUT IN IN FIFTH GRADE FOR HER
SON IN A BATMAN- OUTFIT WHICH
SHE WAS REALLY THRILLED ABOUT
SO ASK ABOUT THAT LATER. SO
AGAIN I LAYS IN GERMAN WE ARE
SO APPRECIATIVE THAT YOU ARE
JOINING US IN PERSON OR ONLINE
IN RESPONSE THE COPING NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES ARE GONNA HAVE TO
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AS WELL AS IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GALLAGHER GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
LACING GENTLEMEN THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS. RIGHTFULLY SO TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. I
WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING TO WASTE
TODAY WILL BE TESTS. HERE IN.
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETEEN ONE
WILL ALSO BE TAKING TESTIMONY
ON OUR LIVE TELECONFERENCE
LINE. IF YOU'D LIKE TO CALLING
ON ANY BILL WE WELCOME YOU. THE
PHONE NUMBER EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
664-436-8774 FOUR SIX. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN THREE THREE SIX
FOUR FOUR THREE SIX THAT CODE
IS. THREE THREE ZERO SIX EIGHT
SIX SIX EIGHT EIGHT REALLY EASY
FOR ME TO SAY- AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE THAT UP ON YOUR SCREEN
HERE SHORTLY. AS HE CAN SEE
THOSE PHONE NUMBERS AT WHEN WE
MOVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'RE
GONNA BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT. IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY IN TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK WE'RE
GONNA ASK YOU TO PLEASE MUTE
YOUR DEVICE THAT YOU'RE
WATCHING ON. RIRE TO GIVING
TESTIMONY AGAIN THAT WILL AVOID
FEEDBACK AND HELP THE HEARING
RUN SMOOTHER. IN THE UNLIKELY
EVENT AN EVENT IN INDIVIDUAL
BECOMES UNRULY EITHER ON THE
PHONE OR AN IN PERSON. THAT
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING OR HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS
MUTED. THAT WHILE EVERY EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE
HEARING PROCESS A CONDUCTOR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE AS THE
SAME MANNERS CUSTOMARY. THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES WHAT IS
GOING TO ASK EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU FOR A BIT OF PATIENCE
TODAY. I PROMISE YOU WE'RE
GONNA GET THROUGH THIS TOGETHER
WE ARE SO GRATEFUL TO THE
AUTHORS WO ARE HERE TODAY.
WE'RE GONNA START ON SENATE
BILL SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT THAT
SENATOR BECKER FOCUSING ON
EXCESSIVE DWELLING UNITS. JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO CENTER
BECKER FOR WORKING. OUT WITH
THIS- AND- LOOK THE BOTTOM LINE
IS- WE- TRULY APPRECIATE HIS
LEADERSHIP. ON AN INNOVATIVE
APPROACH TO EIGHTY USED TO
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR JOINING US. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS. IN
CONTINUED EFFORT TO STRESS THE
STATE'S HOUSING SHORTAGE. SB
SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT WILL HELP
STREAMLINE MIXED USE COMMERCIAL
SPACE CONVERSION. INTO EIGHTY
USE. ASSEMBLY S. B. SEVEN SO A.
CLARIFIES THE OWNERS OF MIXED
USE FOR MULTI FAMILY BUILDINGS.
MAY TURN UNUSED COMMERCIAL
SPACES INTO THESE EXTRA UNITS.
I GLADLY ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
MINUTES TO FIX THE TECHNICAL
TRACKING ERROR AS DESCRIBED IN
NUMBER THREE ON PAGE THREE OF
THE COMMITTEE NOW SAYS. I WANNA
THANK YOU SHARING COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE SWIFT ACTION
TRUMPETED ERROR AND A
COMMITMENT TO CRAFTING STRONG
POLICY. COLLEAGUES ARE STRICTLY
ASPEN AYE VOTE ON SB SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS TWENTY TWO WEEKS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
CENTER BECKER AT LEAST ENGINE
COMMITTEE WORKING AT IT TAKE A
QUICK. ONE MINUTE BREAK GIVE US
ONE MINUTE WE'RE GONNA JUST
DEAL WITH ONE TECHNICAL ISSUE
BEHIND THE SCENES WILL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH YOU ONE MINUTE RECESS.
I DON'T. ALL RIGHT LAYS IN
GERMAN WE DO APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE THANK YOU SO MUCH SO
WHAT WE JUST HEARD AS CENTER
BECKER'S TESTIMONY THANK YOU SO
MUCH E'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING
TO OUR LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS
WE'RE GONNA WELCOME TONY BUSSEY
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IS GOING TO BE ON
THE LINE MISTER BILL YOU ARE
THREE MINUTES I'LL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPTED YOU COME
UPON THAT THREE MINUTES THE
FLOOR IS YOURS YOU'RE NOW IN
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU CHAIR.
AGAIN TWENTY WE WILL BE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT- I'LL KEEP
MY COMMENTS BRIEF. ACCIDENT
RECORDS DATED AT SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT THAT WOULD CLARIFY THE-
LAW AUTHORIZING THE
STREAMLINED. APPROVAL A. B.
ABATING AND UNUSED. ACTUAL END
RESULT SIXTH- THE CLEAR FIVE TO
THE CLUB INCLUDING HE ALLEGED
PAPAGO SIGNED. EIGHT THERE'S NO
OFFICE ON IN- WE RESPECT
ABSOLUTE BELIEVE UP. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER BOWIE WE'RE FOR
TEST TODAY ALL RIGHT IN GERMAN
ORGANIST- YOU THERE IS A WHO
LIKE TO GET THIS BRIEFLY ON
SUPPORT- IN THE HEARING ROOM ON
BEHALF OF SENATE BILL SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT WE ASK YOUR FIRST
AND LAST NAME IN ORGANIZATION
IN SUPPORT. HEARING SEEN NO ONE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE'RE GONNA
CHECK IN WITH MR MODERATOR
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
AT SEVEN. SEVEN EIGHT NOW.
CERTAINLY PLEASE ENTER MENTAL
FREEDOM PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'RE GONNA
BE QUEUING UP FOLKS IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TALK
WITH THE COMMITTEE TODAY ON ANY
BILL PLEASE DIAL. 877-336-4436
MISTER MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
OUR SUPPORT WITNESSES. OUR
FIRST WITNESS. WILL COME FROM
LINE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE PROCEED. ALL RIGHT
MISTER MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COLORS INC YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL MISTER
MODERATOR ALL RIGHT LAYS IN
GERMAN NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION
AT SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN A ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO TO PROVIDE
BRIEF TESTIMONY FIRST AND LAST
NAME ORGANIZATION- IN
OPPOSITION TO SEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. IN SEEN NO ONE WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE. MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
IN OPPOSITION A SEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT CAN YOU PLEASE DO THAT
NOW. CERTAINLY THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE
KILLED BY PHONE ALL RIGHT WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE NOT IN
OPPOSITION TO BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE A TO SEE IF
THERE IS ARE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS- AND OR IS THERE A
MOTION TO APPROVE. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A MOTION BY THE VICE CHAIR
VICE CHAIR NIELSEN IT WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR- INTO
MISTER BECKER I SEEM YOU'RE
GONNA BE TAKING THAT TECHNICAL
AMENDMENT WE APOLOGIZE ABOUT
THAT AS WELL. YES ABSOLUTELY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
AGAIN I TRY TO TAKE AMONG TO
READ. SENT BECKER BEING TODAY
YOUR LEADERS ON THIS. ISSUE THE
IS YOURS FOR CLOTHES- I
APPRECIATE COMMITTEE WORK WITH
US RESPECT ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
REBEKAH FRANK AND WE THIS WE
HAVE A MOST ON THE FLOOR MOTION
THE FLOOR BY. THE VICE CHAIR.
MISTER NOW CAN YOU SPELL THE
FORMAL MOTION IN CALL THE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING. SENATOR MCGUIRE HI
MCGUIRE- A SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN ALL RIGHT SENATOR
DORADO. DRAGO HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER.
THREE ZERO THREE YOUR VOTE LAYS
IN GERMAN WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT
BILL- ON ICE FOR NOW WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP THE ROLE OPEN AT
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE OUR OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT BE ABLE TO
ADD ON A LAZY CHEN WE HAVE TWO
OTHER COMMITTEES MOVING TODAY
SO THERE WILL BE A LOT OF FOLKS
COMING IN AND OUT CENTER BAKER
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'LL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN LAYS IN GERMAN I
NEED ONE MINUTE TO TALK TO OUR
VICE CHAIR AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO WELCOME SENATOR STERN- INTO.
THE HEARING HE'LL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY GIVE ME.
ONE MINUTE PLEASE.
THANK YOU SO
MUCH LACING GENTLEMEN WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE AND
FIRST AND FOREMOST I WANNA
START OUT BY. ETHNOLOGY IN
SENATOR STERN CENTER STERN'S
GONNA BE PROVIDING AN OPENING
STATEMENT THAT I'M GOING TO.
JUMP IN AND JUST SAY A FEW
WORDS BUT- I CENTER STERN. YOUR
PARTNERSHIP ON ALL ISSUES A
WILDFIRE. I CAN'T SAY THANK YOU
ENOUGH. I CENTER STERN HAS BEEN
A LEADER JUST LIKE THE VICE
CHAIR MISTER NIELSEN ON ALL
ISSUES A WILDFIRE HOME
HARDENING INSURANCE- AND I'M
SO. GRATEFUL TO BE WORKING WITH
YOU SIR. WE'RE GOING TO TURN
THE FLOOR OVER TO YOU- FOR AN
OPENING STATEMENT. THAT I HAVE
A FEW WORDS ON S FIFTY FIVE IN
PARTNERSHIP PLEASE CENTER STERN
THE FORCE OR SERVING. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. AND I'M SORRY I
CAN'T BE WITH YOU ALL HERE
TODAY- I WANT TO START BY
THANKING YOU AND YOUR STAFF.
HOW MY AUDIENCE THROUGH OKAY
I'M GETTING A LITTLE ECHO ON MY
LIST ALL RIGHT YOU'RE SOUNDING
GREAT WE DON'T HAVE THE ASK ON
OUR END OKAY GOOD. I'M ALL TO
MYSELF AT THE END THAT PROBABLY
PROVE THINGS SO WHAT IS START
BY THINKING- YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND YOUR STAFF WERE DIGGING SO
DEEP ON THIS ISSUE AND NO WE%
DIDN'T- I JUST WENT OUT NAY
ANALYSIS WE HAD OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS TWO YEARS BACK WE'VE
BEEN TRACKING THIS ISSUE FOR
MANY YEARS- AND YOUR ATTENTION
AND PERSISTENCE. ON FINDING A
WAY TO ADDRESS OUR HOUSING
CRISIS WITHOUT EXACERBATING THE
RISKS OF OUR WILDFIRE CRISIS-
ARE UNPRECEDENTED AND IS
USUALLY APPRECIATED SO IN LIGHT
OF THE EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER
WORK YOU'VE BEEN DOING- WITH SB
TWELVE WHICH WE KNOW PASSED
ADDED THIS COMMITTEE EARLIER-
THIS MONTH- LATE LAST MONTH-
WHAT WE'RE INTENDING TO MAKE SB
FIFTY FIVE BUT A TO YOUR BILL
TODAY. AND SIGNED ON AS A JOINT
AUTHOR- TO S. B. TWELVE- AND
HOPEFULLY FIND SOME
PARTNERSHIP- GOING FORWARD
WHERE ADD THE WHOLE SENATE
WILDFIRE PACKAGE AND HOUSING
PACKAGE START TO REALIZE THAT
S. B. TWELVE- IS A CRITICAL
PIECE OF THAT FORMULA. WE FEEL
IT FIFTY FIVE HERE TODAY
INTENTIONALLY HAS SOME MORE
AGGRESSIVE ELEMENTS IN IT- THEN
S. B. TWELVE- AND SOME OF THAT
MAY MAKE SENSE IN THE FINAL
FRAME WORK BUT- E WILL ADD A
DIFFERENCE BUT ALSO JUST
RESPECT FOR THE LEVEL OF WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE- WE WANNA
HARMONIZE THOSE EFFORTS. AND
HOPEFULLY GET A BILL THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE AND A SIGNATURE
FROM THE GOVERNOR THIS YEAR- AS
WE KNOW WE JUST PASSED HISTORIC
EARLY ACTION FUNDING ON
WILDFIRE PREVENTION- TO
HARDENER COMMUNITIES DO A
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT TO REDUCE
FUEL RISK BUT MONEY ALONE CAN'T
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM- WE NEED TO
CHANGE THE. WAY WE ARE BUILDING
AND ADDRESSING LAN USE IN THE
STATE TO. OURSELVES FOR
BUILDING DEEPER AND DEEPER INTO
VERY HIGH FIRE SEVERITY SOUNDS
WITHOUT SUFFICIENT HARDENING-
EMERGENCY EVACUATION HAZARD
MITIGATION AND OTHER STANDARDS-
THERE ABOUT TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS LIVING
RIGHT NOW IN VERY HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY ZONES. THOSE ARE THE
VERY HIGH FIRE SEVERITY ZONES
THERE'S MILLIONS MORE LIVING AT
HIGH AND MODERATE STONES THAT
HAVE ALSO BEEN HIT AS I KNOW
YOU KNOW ALL TOO WELL MISTER
CHAIR OUT IN. COFFEE PARK IN IN
OTHER AREAS THAT NEVER THOUGHT
OF THEMSELVES AS A FIRE RISK
BUT I WERE HIT NONE THE LESS-
SO. YOU KNOW THE BILL TODAY IS
INTENDED TO LIMIT THAT
DEVELOPMENT IN CASES WHERE
SUFFICIENT PLANNING HAS NOT
BEEN DONE- WE KNOW THAT THE
RESILIENCY EFFORTS AND
HARDENING- CAN BE A HUGE FACTOR
IN KEEPING HOME STANDING IN THE
BUILDING STANDARDS ESPECIALLY
APPLYING THEM BEYOND JUST THE
VERY HIGH ZONES INTO HIGH AND
MODERATE CAN BE. A REALLY
EFFECTIVE PREVENTION METHOD AS
WELL- BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH OF
THE LOSSES WE'VE SEEN IN
PROTECTING HOMES IN THESE AREAS
OF THE LAST THREE YEARS. HAS
BEEN IN THE TENS OF BILLIONS
AND OVER THE LAST DECADE- OVER
FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS IS SPENT.
AND SO WE WANT TO SLOW DOWN THE
PACE OF DEVELOPMENT IN THESE
VERY HIGH FIRE ZONES WTHOUT
HINDERING THE HOUSING CRISIS
AND I REALLY WANT TO JUST TAKE
A SECOND I WON'T BELABOR THIS
BUT I WANT TO THANK THOSE. IN
THE HOUSING COMMUNITY- WHETHER
IT'S YOU ME OR ABUNDANT HOUSING
OR THE OTHERS OF ENGAGE WITH US
AND TRY TO FIND A WAY IN THIS
BILL TO AT LEAST PUT AN IDEA
OUT THERE. ABOUT A DENSITY
BONUS- TO ACCOMPANY ANY
LIMITATIONS IN DEVELOPMENT OF
FIRE ZONES SO THAT INFILL
DEVELOPMENT ANOTHER SUSTAINABLE
DEVELOPMENT WOULD BE SUPER
CHARGED IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO JUST
SAY NO I THINK WE'VE GOT TO SAY
YES AND SAY YES TWICE AS MUCH-
BUT THE FACT IS THAT. THE
DEVELOPMENTS IN THESE HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY ZONES DON'T TEND TO BE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THEY ARE
NOT NECESSARILY THOSE THAT ARE
INTENDED TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS. I IN MY COMMUNITIES
THESE ARE OFTEN MULTI MILLION
DOLLR MANSIONS SITTING ON
HILLTOPS THAT ARE GOING TO PULL
FIREFIGHTERS DEEPER AND DEEPER
INTO HARM'S WAY. THAT ARE
INHERENTLY GOING TO BE
SUBSIDIZED BY THOSE NOT LIVING
IN FIRE ZONES INTO THOSE LIVING
IN THOSE NEW DEVELOPMENTS AND I
FRANKLY DON'T FIND. THAT CROSS
SUBSIDY FARE- I DON'T THINK IT
COMPTON SHOULD BE PAYING. FOR
NEW MANSIONS IN CALABASAS OR IN
MALIBU- AND- I KNOW I REPRESENT
MALIBU AND CALABASAS IN SOME OF
THESE AREAS WHERE WE BURNED
DOWN SO MANY TIMES AND SO IT'S
HARD TO SAY NO IN YOUR OWN
COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY TO- WELL
HEELED FOLKS- BUT- IT'S MY DUTY
I FEEL THE- TO BRING THESE
ISSUES TO LIGHT. AND HOPEFULLY
EDUCATE YOU A LITTLE BIT HERE
TODAY I KNOW YOU'RE BUSY
AGENDAS I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE INDULGENCE MISTER CHAIR-
AND- WE HAVE WE DO HAVE A FEW
WITNESSES YOUR TO GIVE SOME
BRIEF TESTIMONY. MICHAEL WHERE
FROM STANFORD HAS BEEN-
VISIONARY ON ALL THIS WORK AND
REALLY CENTRAL TO SOME OF THE
ARCHITECTURE HERE SO I KNOW
HE'S HERE AND- SOME OTHER SOME
OTHER FIRE EXPERTS IN HOUSING
FOLKS. ON. THE LINE BUT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THE
INDULGE AND THEY AND- LET'S
LET'S GET SOME. WORK THIS YEAR
I DON'T THINK WE CAN JUST RELY
ON EXISTING LAW DESPITE WHAT WE
SEEN IN THE COURTS AS OF LATE.
I THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
GOING TO HAVE TO STEP UP HERE
TOO SO THANKS AGAIN. SENATE
STERN I JUST WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU SO.
CENTER STERN AND I'VE BEEN
ATTACHED AT THE HIP IF YOU
WILL- ON ALI SHE'S A WILDFIRE
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS.
AND HE IS AN ACTIVE AND ENGAGED
MEMBER OF THE WILDFIRE WORKING
GROUP- HE'S CHAIR OF NATURAL
RESOURCES HE'S BEEN ON THE
GROUND- DELIVERING FOR HIS.
RESIDENT FOR THE RESIDENT SAID
HE WORKS FOR A WIN THERE HAVE
BEEN WHILE THEN FIRES- IN HE'S
BEEN SINCERE IN HIS APPROACH.
OF TRYING TO CHANGE THE CYCLE
CHANGE THE BROKEN CYCLE OF
DOING THE SAME THING OVER AND
OVER. IN CONTINI SEE. HOMES AND
BUILDINGS BURNED SAID IN FACT
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
WE'VE SEEN SEEN THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND HOMES THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND HOMES AND BUILDINGS.
BURNED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT IS WHY I
CENTER STERN AND I ARE
PARTNERING. ON THIS ISSUE ON
THIS LEGISLATION AT TO BE ABLE
TO BRING COMMONSENSE STANDARDS.
FOR HEALTH AND SAFETY- AND
THAT'S ALL THIS IS ABOUT IS
ABOUT SAVING LIVES IN MAKING
OUR COMMUNITIES MORE SAFE- AND
AGAIN CENTER STERN. YOU HAVE
MOVED THE BAR HI. AND WE'VE
LEARNED SO MUCH FROM YOU AND
KNOW THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
WORKING TOGETHER ON THIS
SPECIFIC ISSUE AS A JOINT. BOTH
OF US ARE JOINT AUTHORS. ON SB
TWELVE AYE HE HAS SOME REALLY
CRITICAL LEGISLATION REALLY
REALLY CRITICAL PIECES IN. SB
FIFTY FIVE ON LANDSLIDES AS
WELL AS AIR QUALITY THAT I
THINK IS. REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE FOCUS ON AS
WELL. SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD
TO PARTNERING WITH SENATOR
STERN HERE IN THE WEEKS AND
MONTHS TO COME TO BE ABLE TO
GET THIS BILL PASSED AND WE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO DO IT JUST
BEING HONEST ABOUT IT. WITHOUT
CENTERS STERN SO SINISTER AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP.
CENTER STERN IS GONNA BE
HANGING WITH US RIGHT NOW IS
WE'RE GONNA BE GOING. TO OUR
LEAD SUPPORT AND LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS IS. FIRST
AND FOREMOST GOING TO BE
INVITING. I PROFESSOR MICHAEL.
ARE HE'S A DIRECTOR OF THE
CLIMATE ENERGY POLICY PROGRAM.
AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY AT MR
WATER HAS THREE MINUTES IN WILL
BE ARE GOING TO OUR TELEPHONE
LINES. IF YOU ARE WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE YOU ARE NOW IN
COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
CENTER MCGUIRE AND I'LL JUST
SAY. I AM HONORED TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU- AND TO BE WORKING
WITH THE SENATE ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. I'M HAVING THE
SAME ISSUE THAT- SENATORS EARN
HAVE HAD WITH AN ECHO SO I'M
GONNA TRY TO SPIN OUT- SB
THIRTY FIVE IS A BILL THAT
WOULD REQUIRE STAFF- BEFORE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS COULD BUILD
NEW HOUSING IN HIGH FIRE RISK
AREAS AND AT THE SAME TIME-
WELL THE SAMETIME MAKE IT
EASIER AND APPROVING ECONOMICS
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING LOW
RISK AREA. IT SAYS NO KIND OF
RISKY HOUSING WITHOUT PLANNING
WHILE SAYING YEAH OTHER STATE I
THINK THAT'S EXACTLY THE
DIRECTION CALIFORNIA HAD IN ITS
HOUSING POLICY WITH RESPECT TO
WILDFIRE. I WE THE REALITY IS
AS AS- SENATOR WHAT IRON
STANDARD. INDICATED WERE LOSING
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF HOUSING
UNITS WILDFIRE. AND THAT'S EVEN
AS WE STRUGGLE TO BUILD ENOUGH
NEW HOUSING MAKE IT. CALIFORNIA
CAN YOU TO BE IN AFFORDABLE
ATTRACTIVE PLACE. FOR FAMILIES
TO LIVE. CATASTROPHIC FIRES
ALSO HAD A BIG IMPACT ON THE
PEOPLE WHOSE HOMES BURNED DOWN
ALSO ON RENTERS IN NEARBY
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE INSURANCE
COMPENSATION FOR FIRE VICTIMS
LOSE. REPLACEMENT HOUSE. THOUGH
IN SANTA ROSA AND KEEP OUT OF
THIS BUT A WIDESPREAD BRENT.
AND ELECTION FOR LONGTIME
RESIDENTS. AFTER THE TOP
EMPIRES POUNDING THE COMMUNITY
IMPACT OF THESE NATURAL
DISASTERS. I THINK SB FIFTY
FIVE IN A KIND OF PLANNING THAT
IT REQUIRES IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
OVER THE LIFETIME OF THE HOUSE
INSTRUCTED TODAY CLIMATE CHANGE
AND CONTINUE TO GET WORSE
DESPITE THE EFFORTS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE UNITED
STATES AND THE GLOBAL EFFORTS
ON CLIMATE. THE RISKS ARE VERY
LIKELY TO DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE- OR HOUSE IS LOCATED
IN THE BEER AT HIGH AND
MODERATE- BOB PERHAPS ARE. THE
CURRENT SCIENCE THE BEST WE
UNDERSTAND IT YES THAT TWENTY
TO FORTY FIRE SEASON LIKE THE
ONE WE JUST EXPERIENCED WERE
FOUR MILLION ACRES BURNING
CALIFORNIA COULD BE. AVERAGE
NOT TO ORDINARY THAT MEANS WE
NEED TO BE THINKING AHEAD
PARTICULARLY FOR LONG LIVED
ASSETS LIKE- NEW DEVELOPMENT AS
WE PLAN. ON IT WE DO HAS ARE
PLANNING. IN ADDITION PASSED
THE POINT OUT THE COST OF THIS
NEW HOUSING INTO BARS OF
PRESSURE THE POTENTIAL GROWING
LAST YEAR WE SPENT MORE THAN
THREE BILLION ON WILDFIRE
SUPPRESSION. BUT THE RECORD ONE
CONSISTENT WITH MULTI YEAR
TREND. SB FIFTY FIVE WOULD DO
TWO THINGS I THINK ARE
IMPORTANT IN SEXUALLY TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND I WOULD
ALSO AMEND THE EFFORT ON OTHER
BILLS RELATED TO PLANNING
SESSION. ONE IS. REQUIRE
PLANNING REQUIRE COMPREHENSIVE
MITIGATION AFTER PLANNING
BEFORE WE PUT PEOPLE. READ
COMMUNITY RESIDENTS AND
FIREFIGHTERS IN HARM'S WAY NOT
UNREASONABLE TO ASK THAT GIVEN
THE RISKS WE FACE AND HAVE
EXPERIENCED. THAT CAN IT THE
STATEYEAH HOUSING WHERE IT
STATE. EVEN AS WE MAKE IT
SOMEWHAT MORE CHALLENGING AND
MORE EXPENSIVE BILL HOUSING
WHERE IT'S UNSAFE. I THINK
THAT'S A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
GETTING TO A SOLUTION AND IF
BASS ON HOUSING ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S RESIDENCE. SAFELY
AND AFFORDABLY THANK YOU.
PROFESSOR ARE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR GRAVE OF YOUR TESTIMONY AT
ONE I CHECK IN A QUICK
HOUSEKEEPING PURPOSES OR I DID
THAT ECHO GET ANY BETTER FOR
YOU DURING YOUR TESTIMONY SIR.
YEAH IT ACTUALLY DID I'M NOT
QUITE SURE WHAT HAPPENED BUT IT
DISAPPEARS. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO
TO CHECK IN WITH THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE PROFESSOR OF OUR
WAS OUR ONE LEAD WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY FIVE THANK
YOU AGAIN MR PROFESSOR. WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL SEEN IF ANYONE IT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIFTY FIVE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. HERE IN C. NOW
AND WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO
OUR TELECONFERENCE ON. THAT
WE'RE GONNA WELCOME ANYONE AND
EVERYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY
FIVE. ON A TELESCOPE
TELECONFERENCING. TO PLEASE HIT
THE- ONE ZERO NOW. MISTER
MODERATOR THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THIS GET FOLKS. QUEUED UP FOR
SB FIFTY FIVE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO FIRST WE HAVE
LINE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE MR MODERATOR.
NEXT WE GO TO LINE. SIXTY ONE.
GOOD MORNING LINE SIXTY ONE
YEAR IN COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE MR MODERATOR. YOU KNOW
FOR THE COLORS IN Q. MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS THE MODERATOR WE'RE
GONNA BE BACK WITH YOU HERE
JUST IN A FEW MOMENTS WE'RE
GOING TO NOW GO TO OUR LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES- WE DO
HAVE TO ON FILE TODAY. THAT
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
SILVIO FERRARI REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION I MISTER FERRARI
YOU WILL HAVE THREE MINUTES
WE'LL GIVE YOU A THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU
ARE NOW IN COMMITTEE. ON SB
FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE THAT. AND
I'M I'M ALSO GET THAT OUT SO-
MR WEEK IN. RESERVE FOR YOU
WHAT IF YOU DON'T MIND WE'RE
GONNA HAVE YOU PAUSE FOR A
SECOND. MISTER FERRARI
APOLOGIZE BUT WE WANT TO GET
THIS FIGURED OUT SO WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO. WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
FEW MINUTE BREAK. MISTER
FERRARI WE'RE GONNA COME BACK
TO YOU ALONG WITH MR RAGEL FROM
THE CHAMBER. TO BE A TO PROVIDE
YOUR TESTIMONY WE WANT TO GET
THIS THING IN THE BUD HERE. SO
WE'RE GOING TO KICK START THE
SYSTEM. IN WILL BE BACK WITH
THE OPPOSITION ON SB FIFTY FIVE
WE APOLOGIZE. GIVE US A FEW
MINUTES WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU.
ALL RIGHT LAYS IN
GERMAN AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WE'RE GONNA TRY THIS
AGAIN WE DID WE REBOOT WE GOT
THE HAMSTERS FED AND THEY'RE
MOVING SO- IT'S GOOD STUFF- IN
DIFFERENT KEEP THIS MOVING AT
FIRST I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO MISTER FERRARI MR RAGEL FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WITH US- WE HAVE
OUR TO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES EACH YEAR RECIEVE
THREE MINUTES WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE GET THAT ECHO RD REAR.
MISTER FERRARI I WANT TO DO A
QUICK TECH CHECK WITH YOU
THOUGH SIR MISTER FERREIRA HOW
WE COMING IN IS THAT ECHO I
DISAPPEAR. AT SENATOR IT SOUNDS
LIKE IT HAD CLEARED OUT THAT
SOUNDS GOOD ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD MISTER FERRARI YOU ARE NOW
IN COMMITTEE. YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE SIR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS- GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT. YEAH THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AGAINST WILL
BE- FERRARI HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION- WE ARE OPPOSED AS-
FIFTY FIVE. WE DO NOT- WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT A PROHIBITION
APPROACH TO HOUSING- IS PRUDENT
GIVEN THAT SEVERITY THE HOUSING
CRISIS THAT WE FACE TODAY- WE I
THINK ARE ALL WELL AWARE THAT.
IN CALIFORNIA- EVERY SQUARE
INCH OF BUILDABLE LAND IS
SUBJECT TO AT LEAST ONE NATURAL
DISASTER RANGING FROM FIRE TO
FLOOD AND EARTHQUAKE AND THE
LIST GOES ON. MITIGATION IS
REALLY FAST AND THE ONLY WAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN BALANCE
REST. WITH THE HOUSING CRISIS
THAT WE FIND OURSELVES IN AND A
CRISIS THAT CONTINUES TO GET
WORSE WITH EVERY PASSING YEAR-
UNFORTUNATELY. WE ARGUE A FIFTY
FIVE IS IT. THAT IT TAKES THAT
THE OF PROHIBITION APPROACH AND
GOES TOO FAR. WE HAVE SEEN-
WITH. MASTER PLANNED COMMUNITY
AFTER MASTER PLANNED COMMUNITY
THAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY. TO
IMPROVE AN ACTIVE FIRE SAFETY
REGULATIONS. THE NEW
DEVELOPMENT CAN BE BUILT. IN
VERY SAFE WAYS IN FIRE PRONE
AREAS THOSE. REGULATIONS THOSE
FIRE SAFETY REQUIREMENTS ARE
WORKING. THEIR PROVEN
EFFECTIVE. AND THEY ARE BEING
PROTECTIVE OF ME COMMUNITIES-
CENTER STURDINESS COMMENTS.
MADE SEVEN I WANTED TO RAISE
WHICH WAS- YOU KNOW THAT THE
NOTION THAT THESE ONE OFF MULTI
MILLION DOLLAR HOMES. ARE BEING
BUILT BEEPER IN DEEPER AND
PULLING FIRE SERVICES FURTHER
AWAY. AND I DON'T THINK C. B. I
WOULD DISAGREE WITH THAT BUT-
OUR MEMBERS. ARE OVERWHELMINGLY
BUILDING MASTER PLANNED
COMMUNITIES. AND WITH MASTER
PLANNED COMMUNITIES CALMNESS
AND ABILITY. TO MINIMIZE FIRE
RISK AND MAXIMIZE FIRED THE
SPENT- OUR MEMBERS ARE BUILDING
EIGHTY FIVE PLUS. PERCENT OF
THE HOUSING CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
THE FOLKS WHO ARE BRINGING. THE
VAST MAJORITY. OF HOMES THAT
ARE. TO EVERYDAY CAL. TO THE.
WE LOOK TO FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS AND SENATE BILL
TWELVE. THAT IS DIRECTLY SHOULD
BE PART OF THAT THIS. SO
SENATORS- MISTER THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME WE REALLY APRECIATE
SENATOR STERN MAKING AT YEAR
BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS THROUGH SB TWELVE
THANK YOU. THANKS SO MUCH AS A
FERRARI ADDED CENTER AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SITTING DOWN WITH
YOU IS SINISTER AND WILL BE.
WORKING WITH THAT STRICTLY NEED
TO THE MEETING SO WE DO
APPRECIATED SIR WE'RE NOT GOING
TO TURN TO MISTER RAGEL FROM
THE- TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. MISTER
RIGO WE WELCOME YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE SIR YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT. FOR
RESOURCE. THANK YOU MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ADAM RIGHT WITH
THAT. CHAMBER OF COMMERCE- IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTY FIVE.
I'M OPPOSITION. WHETHER THE
LEGISLATURE BAND HOUSING RIGHT
AREAS WHERE UP WE HURDLES THAT
EFFECTIVELY. DENY RIFT. HOW THE
NORTH SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASES
CAUGHT. YEAH COMMITTEE REALLY
THANK LEFT HOUSING GET THE-
THEM SUPPLY AND- CALIFORNIA
WORSE THAN. HOME PRICES THAT
ARE GO UP. AND REALLY DREAM OF
OWNING A HOME AND CAL. FROM
BECAUSE YOU MORE OF REACH. WE
DO AGREE WITH SENATOR START
PROFESSOR ARE THE ATTIC HOUSING.
ADEQUATE PLANNING IS NOT. TO ME.
AND ARMY. AGREE ALREADY DO THAT
THE HIGHEST INTO THE- WE
FURTHER AGREED EXIST LAWN HOW
THE IS IN THE- TO FILL THE
THREE POINT. MILLION HOMES NEED.
IN THE STATE AND WE AGREED THE
LEGISLATURE STEP UP TO MEET THE
MOMENT ON HOW THEY- INCLUDING
INFILL BENEFIT. LIKE THAT THE
BONE IT WOULD WE DO APPRECIATE
IT. BUT YOU AFTER YEAR PRO
PRODUCTION HOW BILLS THAT. AGNI
BROUGH ON MORE INFO HOUSING GET
VOTER DOWN. AND THAT THANK.
BILL LIKE SB FIVE FIVE FURTHER
SWEET THE CAL HOWSUPPLY BY
REMOVE LARGE WALK WITH COULD
OFF THE TABLEFOR MORE HOW THEY-
I PLAYED A CALMATTERS ARTICLE
JUST DAYS AGO A PLANE GREAT
DETAIL MANY OF THE FACT DRIVING.
COSTS IN THE HOW THE CRISIS
GENERAL CAL. AND THE NUMBER ONE
CALL THE HOUSE IS LAND VALUE. I
POINT YOU ALL THE TO TODAY'S
HOME PRICE IS ABOUT HUNDRED
THOUSAND. AND IS DRIVING FOLKS
NOT ONLY OUT OF STATE OR CROWD
LIVING BUT ALSO ON HOME THE.
THERE IS NO SUCH THING IN THE
RISK HOUSING. BUT THERE ARE
WAYS THE BILL THE PAPER AND OUR-
THE- IN NEED A- THAT THE
REPRESENTED PDI JUST ARE. THESE
MASSIVE CAN PLAN BE BUILT.
DIRECTLY PROTECT ME. WE THINK
IT IS AN CHEN COMPARED THE BILL
HALF OF. AGO TO NEW HOME
BECAUSE- ANY MASTER PLAN
COMMUNITY BUILT THEM RIGOROUS
FIRING EARLY. IN THE WORLD. WE
UNDER APPRECIATE THE CONCERN TO
PROTECT COMEDIANS WILDFIRE. THE
CALIFORNIA IS FACING TO IN A-
LINKED HI BE. REOCCURRING WALL
AND ON AT THE HOW CRISIS. HOW
THE STATE AND TO ADDRESS ONE.
SHOULD NOT. OF WITH THE WITH
THE- CAL MUST BE THIS MOM PATH
ALL FEEDBACK. KNOCKED TO BRING
AS MUCH RESPONSIBLY. HOW THE-
INTERNET. NEEDED TO CONTINUALLY
LIVE AND WORK IN THE STATE. WE
ALSO BELIEVE WE MUST ALLOW
RESPONSIBLE DEVELOPERS WERE
WILLING TO BUILD THE TITANIC TO
BRING AFFORDABLE HOUSING ONLINE
THIRTY SECONDS STRONGLY OPPOSE
ANY LEGISLATION APPLYING ONE
SIZE FITS ALL HOUSING BAND. OR
OTHERWISE PLATE LEGAL HURDLES
WHICH WILL JEOPARDIZE THE RATE
PROP AND CRITICALLY NEEDED
HOUSING. I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH BOTH
CHAIR. AND BETTER STERN WILL
REPORT ON A WALL OUR
LEGISLATION AND HEALTHY THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THIS REGULARLY
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND AGAIN
THANKS FOR HANGING WITH US- IN
WORKING WITH US AS WE GET THE
SYSTEM BACK UP AND RUNNING WE
APPRECIATED SIR. ALRIGHT
BASINGER AND WE ARE NOT GOING
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. SB FIFTY FIVE HERE
IN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE WE'RE
GONNA ASK YOU TO PLEASE KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS ARE FIRST LAST
NAME ORGANIZATION- IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL CURRENTLY
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION WE WELCOME
THE MAN. COME ON COME ON UP.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING COMMITTEES. SO MICHAEL GO
ARE YOU TO LIVE YOUR DESK. AND
I WAS DISPLACED BY THE TUBBS
FIRE I NOW LIVE IN SENATOR
NIELSEN'S DISTRICT. SO I'M
GOING TO ASK YOU FOR THE
COURTESY OF THIRTY SECONDS AS A
DISPLACED PERSON FROM THE TUBBS
FIRE WE'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY
SECONDS MA'AM IN HIS SEARCH
NOW. MY NAME IS SANDRA HAD
STRUM MY AFFILIATION IS A
DISPLACED PERSON FROM THE TUBBS
FIRE AND WHAT I HEAR YOU SAYING
IS THIS IS SOME KIND OF A
NATURAL DISASTER ISSUE. I WANT
TO DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
FACT THAT BRANDON REGIMENT OF
ABC TEN IN JULY OF NINETEEN
REPORTED THAT EIGHT OUT OF TEN
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE ACCEPTED CAMPAIGN
DONATIONS FROM CORPORATE FELON
PG&E. SIMILARLY ACCORDING TO A
WASHINGTON POST ATICLE GAVIN
NEWSOM ACCEPTED AT SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
PG&E AND THAT FROM AND THEN I
CAN COME OF CORPORATE GREED. I
AM A DISPLACED PERSON MY
CHILDREN HAVE GIVEN TESTIMONY
IN THIS BUILDING ABOUT HOW
SCARY IT WAS FOR THEM TO WAKE
UP WITH THEIR CITY ON FIRE. AND
YOUR LEGISLATING. WHEN YOUR EX
BLOOD FOR EARLY MONEY GIVE YOU
THIRTY IS ASKED. IN ABIDED BY
THAT I'M GRAY HERE TO. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MA'AM WE'RE GONNA
YOU TO. WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
WE'RE TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE WE'D
LOVE TO HAVE YOU STAY IN WE'D
LOVE TO HAVE YOU SAYING
COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA HAVE YOU
TAKE A SEAT WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
HER TESTIMONY. OKAY WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE'LL SEE
YOU NEXT WEEK. YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SOLEIL'S GERMAN WE
ARE NOW GOING TO BE GOING TO
OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE WE
WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY.
877-336-4436 MISTER MODERATOR
WE ARE NOW GOING TO BE LOOKING
TO ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. FIFTY FIVE
CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE THEM UP
NOW MISTER MODERATOR. THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW. FIRST
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIX NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE SIXTY NINE
YEAR AND COMMITTEE. HI THIS
NEXT CALLER PLEASE MR MODERATOR.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CATHERINE FREEMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTY FIVE
THANK YOU THINK SHIKON AND
CATHERINE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
TRACY GARDEN CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
OFFICIALS SPEAKING IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO SB
FIFTY FIVE- WE'RE ENCOURAGED BY
SOME OF THE CHANGES FROM BEFORE
SEVENTY FOUR LAST YEAR WITH
SENATOR OFFICE. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO MORE CONVERSATIONS
WITH DOCTORS OFFICE ON THIS
BILL AS I LOOK UP INTO THE
TWENTY TO START THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY TESTIMONY THAT'S TO
OUR CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE EIGHTY FOUR. PLEASE GO
AHEAD- MY NAME IS WILLIAM TRONG
I'M WITH MOTHER STOCKS FROM
SILICON VALLEY IN THE IF THIRD.
TWO THANK YOU SO MUCH AT WORK
KERN TAKING- TESTIMONY THIS
TIME IN OPPOSITION OF FIFTY
FIVE OF MISTER MARK CAN YOU DO
A CALL. FOR OPPOSITE OF SB.
FIFTY FIVE. CERTAINLY TO ONCE
AGAIN REGION CHEN GENTLEMAN FOR
OPPOSITION TO FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS. FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW FOR
US. IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ONE
PERSON QUEUING RIGHT NOW AS WE
SPEAK. ALL RIGHT. NOW WE HAVE
LINE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI CHRIS WHERE EXACTLY
WOULD WESTERN MANUFACTURED
HOUSING COMMUNITIES THAT. AND
NOT THE TO THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL. IT'S
MODERATOR THAT'S GOING TOWARD
CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE NO FOR
THE COLORS INC YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU WORK WITH A MODERATE
WE IT WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING
WITH YOU IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS
WE'RE GOING TO BE COMING BACK
TO COMMITTEE. LAYS IN GERMAN
COMMITTEE THIS IS TESTIMONY
ONLY TESTIMONY ONLY NO VOTE
WILL BE TAKEN BUT WE'RE GOING
TO OPEN IT UP TO SEE IF THERE'S
QUESTIONS COMMENTS PLEASE
MISTER VICE CHAIR WE WELCOME
USER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MORE IN THE LINE OF
COMMENTS. WHAT WE'VE COME TO
NOW WITH THESE CATACLYSMIC
FIRES IS NOT THE PRODUCT OF
JUST NOW IT'S DECADES DECADES
OF NEGLECT OF OUR FORESTS AND
OUR WILDLANDS MANAGING THOSE
FORESTS AND WILDLANDS. INSTEAD
OUR POLICIES HAVE BEEN JUST TO
LOCK THEM UP AND DO NOTHING.
AND NOW WE HAVE SUFFERED. IF
THERE'S ANYTHING GOOD HAS COME
OUT OF THIS IS THESE FIRES HAVE
GOTTEN SO BIG THEY'VE
ENCROACHED ON MORE URBAN AREAS.
AND NOW THOSE IN THE RURAL
AREAS THOSE ROUGH WHO REPRESENT
THESE ERRORS. WELCOME THE
SUPPORT AND THE- OF PEOPLE IN
URBAN TO NOW AFFECT. AND NOT A
THOSE WHO FACE A FIRE PROBLEM
BUT THIS. THAT IS SET A DISEASE.
YES IS NOT MORE RICH. WELL PART
OF THAT BUT THAT IS NOT BIGGEST
AND THE DIFFICULT HERE AND I
KNOW THAT CENTER FOR WELL THE
NEEDS CERTAINLY OF THOSE PEOPLE
THAT OUR COMMON AND PRAISING
BEING NOW. BUT THIS BILL
ADDRESSES TOO MANY RISK ALUM
AND FRANKLY WHAT THE STAND
YEARS LITIGATION. ENVIRONMENTAL
TO ARE JUST AFTER IT'S LIKE
LIKE THIS IT YOU MORE MORE
OPPORTUNE. TO IN IN PRAGUE. IN
HOUSING THE IN OUR ROOM EVERY.
OR OUR SERVER ISING AREA I CALL
THAT ANOTHER KIND OF
GOVERNMENTS ISING FARAGE. WE
NEED TO ADDRESS THE SETTINGS
BUTTON WITH THAT IF SUCH
SPECIAL. AND NOT WITH SO MUCH
RISK TO GUN. AND IN THE
LEGISLATION IN A NEW ENTITY IF
WE DIDN'T HAVE A ALL AT THE
STATE GO LEVEL. WE NOW HAVE
GOVERNOR OFFICE PLANNING IN
RESEARCH IN. AND TRYING TO
THEIR AND I DON'T SEE THAT
CONSTRUCTIVE I SEE THEM BEING
HELPFUL TO THE ADMINISTRATION
BUT NOT CERTAINLY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SO. I KNOW THAT THE
SENATORS IS WILLING TO WORK I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR MAKING
IT A TO YOUR BILL SO WE MAY
HAVE FOR THE TIME TO DELIBERATE
I WILL CERTAINLY WORK WITH HIM
IN GOOD FAITH TOWARDS THAT END.
BUT TODAY I- YOU WE'RE NOT
WE'RE GOING TO GET TESTIMONY
TODAY SO I'M JUST REFLECTING ON
SOME OF THE CONCERNS AS WE MOVE
AHEAD THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THE VICE YOU'RE ALWAYS VERY
GRATEFUL WE'RE GONNA SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS PLEASE
CENTER DRAWS OF FLOORS YOURS-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND- I
VERY VERY MUCH APPRECIATE US
SENATOR STERN'S. REMARKS AND
HOW WE ARTICULATED THE
CONNECTION THAT. WE ALL HAVE
WITH EACH OTHER AND THE MOMENT
WE SEPARATE OURSELVES OR
ISOLATE OURSELVES THEN WE GET
INTO BIGGER TROUBLE AND I THINK
THAT'S PART OF WHAT'S GONE ON
IS WHEN THERE IS A-
CONTAMINATION ISSUE OR CLIMATE
CHANGE ISSUE AND ONE PART OF
THE STATE. IT'S ALMOST LIKE
OKAY WELL THAT'S THEIR PROBLEM
AND THEN- WHEN WE DON'T MAKE
THE CONNECTION TO THE ISSUES AS
THEY'RE HAPPENING IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE'S AND
COMMUNITIES. SO ARE I REALLY
APPRECIATE- THE CONNECTIONS
THAT SENATOR STERN- MAKING AND
I HOPE AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE
KEEP THAT IN- WE KEEP THAT IN
MIND BECAUSE WE HAVE TO SPEAK
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS I CARE
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS IN THE- YOU
KNOW HIGH FIRE- VERY HIGH FIRE
HAZARD ZONES. AS MUCH AS I DO
WITH GOING ON WITH OFF THE
EXIDE PLANT ENOUGH IN EAST LA
AND VERMONT. YOU KNOW SOME
PEOPLE MIGHT SAY WELL THAT
DOESN'T HAVE TO DO ONE WAY THE
OTHER. IT DOES WHEN WE'RE TO-
MAKE SURE WE LIVE IN A LOT WITH
CLEAN AIR WATER AND WE DON'T
HAVE THE THREATS. OF THINGS
LIKE FIRES- ENCROACHING ON THE
SOAP. OF THAT MAY BE A FAR
FETCHED CONNECTION I DON'T
THINK SO BUT I JUST- JUST TOOK
TO KEEP ALL OF THAT IN MIND
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
DRAWS A VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS FROM THE
COMMITTEE ASKING CLOTHING.
REMARKS AND IN TURN OVER
SINISTER AFTER THAT. HEARING C.
NON I THINK THE IMPORTANT PIECE
OF THIS IS LOOK. UP WE KNOW.
THAT DEVELOPMENT AS USUAL.
CAN'T CONTINUE TO HAPPEN.
LEISER LITTLE AT RISK- WE KNOW
THAT THERE REMAINS CONCERNED
ABOUT PLANE COMMUNITIES- IS
ACTIVE LITIGATION ON- TIE RANCH
TEJON RANCH. WE'RE NOT VALLEY
IN OUR NECK OF THE WOODS BASS
ALPHA OF BUT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SAYS IS INADEQUATE
PREPAREDNESS WHEN IT COMES TO
DEVELOPMENT- FIRE SAFETY WHERE
THOSE HOMES ARE CURRENTLY BEING
BUILT LITERALLY TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOMES AND RESORTS
ROOMS ACROSS THE STATE. SO WE
KNOW WE HAVE TO DO BETTER I
THIS IS NOT AT ALL THROWING
STONES BUT JUST THE FACT IN THE
TIME THAT WE'RE LIVING IN RIGHT
NOW THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND HOMES
AND BUILDINGS HAVE BEEN LOST IN
THE LAST SIX YEARS. SIX YEARS.
THAT'S AN ENTIRE. COMMUNITY SO
LOOK BOTTOM LINE IS CENTER
STERN IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK. DILIGENTLY ON THIS ISSUE
HAS BEEN A LEADER IN THIS ISSUE
HE'S LEADERSHIP FUNDS THAT
LEADERSHIP. HE SHOWN LEADERSHIP
NOW HE'S GOING TO SHOW
LEADERSHIP IN THE FUTURE ON ALL
ISSUES OF FIRES AND DEVELOPMENT
CENTER STERN WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP WILL HAVE YOU
DO THE CLOTHES. THANK YOU FOR.
HAVING THIS DEBATE IN THIS
CONVERSATION I KNOW YOU HAVE A
PACKED AGENDA SO I'LL JUST
BRIEFLY SAY MY CLOSE TO TWO
POINTS OF FACT FOR THE RECORD
AS WE GO FORWARD ONE IS. THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE BILL I JUST
TO BE CLEAR CHANGE THE
ORIENTATION SO IT IS NOT.
TAKING AWAY LOCAL CONTROL THAT
A GENERAL PLAN THAT ADOPTS
SUFFICIENTLY RIGOROUS STANDARDS
CAN STILL. DEVELOP INTO RURAL
OR SUBURBAN AREAS SO OUR
INTENTION WAS NOT TO BE A HEAVY
HANDED AND- TAKING AWAY LOCAL
CONTROL AND THE SAME GOES FOR
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO REBUILD
THEIR HOMES AFTER FIRE. A
SECOND JUST LASTLY TO SENATOR
RISES POINT ON THE
INDIVISIBILITY OF JUSTICE
THERE'S A REASON STANFORD STUDY
THAT I WOULD POINT OUT TO YOU
ALL. THEY TALKED ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF THE WILDFIRE SMOKE
OVER LAST WINTER DURING THE
HEART OF THE PANDEMIC OF THE
IMPACTS WE MAY SEE ON LONG
HEALTH AND DEVELOPMENT THAT MAY
NOT HAVE BEEN NOTICED. BECAUSE
COVE IT WAS SUCH A LOUD
PRESENCE IN RESPIRATORY IMPACT
BUT THAT THEY HAVE NOW DETECTED
PERMANENT DAMAGE GENETIC DAMAGE
FROM THAT WILDFIRE SMOKE. ON
CHILDREN'S LUNGS AND URBAN
AREAS. TRIGGERING SEVERE
PERMANENT AS MUCH AND THEY
THEY'RE WORKING ON THE MATH BUT
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS OF PRETERM
BIRTHS AS WELL- HAD ON THIS
MOST TAXED TO KIND OF AIR
POLLUTION SO I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE. THAT HOLISTIC VIEW
THE SENATOR RAZA PUT FORD. AND
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THE FUTURE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SINISTER
RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN THAT IS
TESTIMONY ONLY ON SB FIFTY FIVE
IN LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE WITH THE CENTER
STERN SHOW. WE'RE NOW MOVING ON
TO ITEM NUMBER THREE THIS IS SB
FOUR EIGHTY ON OUR FILE TODAY.
FOCUS ON THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. SINISTER AND WE
WELCOME YOU BACK TO FLOOR IS
YOURS ON SB. FOUR EIGHTY. THANK
YOU MISTER SHE- THE BILL IS
TRYING TO ADDRESS- SO SYSTEM.
PROBLEM WE'VE SEEN IN THE
MEASURE WATER- ILLUMINATED BY
RECENT EVENTS REGARDING
TROUBLING REPORTS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ANOTHER-
UNACCEPTABLE IN APPROPRIATE-
AND INCREDIBLY PROBLEMATIC
CONDUCT- BY EMPLOYEES AT M. W.
D. WE KNOW HOW CRUCIAL THIS
WATER DISTRICT IS TO THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND IN FACT AT A
POLICY LEVEL APPLAUD THEM ON
MUCH OF THEIR LEADERSHIP BUT
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN RECENT YEARS
HAS BEEN ANYTHING BUT- WHEN IT
COMES TO. THE ETHICS- AND
SAFETY ATTENTION FROM- FROM
MANY EMPLOYEES- THAT WE HOPE
THIS BILL WILL I SET THEM BACK
ON COURSE WE KNOW THAT THERE IS
CURRENTLY AN AUDIT UNDER WAY AS
WELL AS AN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION- AND THERE ARE
CERTAINLY THINGS THAT THEY CAN
AND SHOULD BE ADDRESSED- WITH
THAT WHATEVER THE OUTCOME OF
THAT AUDIT OUR INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION IS. NO PERSON
SHOULD FEEL UNSAFE AT WORK- AND
THOSE TO TAKE CARE OF OUR WATER
SYSTEM IT SHOULD HAVE SAFETY
ABOVE ALL ELSE AS A CENTRAL
METRIC NO ROOM FOR ABUSE
DISCRIMINATION HARASSMENT FOR
ANY MEMBER OF OUR SOCIETY WE'VE
DEALT WITH SOME OF THESE IN
HOUSE IN OUR OWN LEGISLATURE-
SO WE'RE USING SOME OF THOSE
SAME TOOLS HERE HOPEFULLY SETS
AND NEW STANDARDS- FOR MAC TO
ADOPT AND RULES FOR HOW THEIR
VALUES AND DEDICATION THEREFORE
YOU SHOULD BE RESPECTED IN
THEIR CODE WITH THAT- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
I THINK WE HAVE ALLEN STANDING
IN HERE- VICE PRESIDENT OF ASK
ME LOCAL NINETEEN OH TWO. THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTERS STERN WE
ARE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO OUR
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSING AFTER
RIGHT TO MISTER SHANNON COMING
IN THE INTERNET VICE FOR
CALIFORNIA ASKED ME MR WE YOU
TO COMMITTEE YOU HVE THREE
MINUTES TO BE AT A PRESENT IN
THEN I'LL GIVE YOU A THIRTY
PROMPT MR SHANAHAN YOU'RE IN.
THE FLOORS. PLEASE THANK YOU
CHAIR MY STERN MAY OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR YEARS PROPERTY TO
COME YOU THIS MORNING SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR EIGHTY- WE THINK
SENATORS FORGIVE OUR MEMBERS A
VOICE HEARD SAYING THIS BILL
EVER MORE IMPORTANT AS WE TO
MAKE W. D. A MORE JOHN A MAC
WORK AND PUBLIC AGENCIES IS
HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND HAS
PROPER- OVERSIGHT ASKED ME
LOCAL MIGHT TO. NEARLY 80% OF
THE WORK FOR THAT METROPOLITAN
WATER TO AS WELL AS EITHER
WATER AND SOUTHERN CAL. AND
FOUR EIGHT ISN'T STEP TOWARDS
IN ACCOUNT OF AND OVERSIGHT AND
D. THAT IS A AID TO HELD SEEMS
TO AS OTHER PART KENNEDY AND
MODELS WILL EXPECT PUBLIC
AGENTS AND CAL WHICH IS NOW
TODAY. THIRTEEN SB FOUR MAKES
TO THEM TO BE THE ACT
STRENGTHENING THE MBTA ETHIC
OFF OVER IS MORE AND FOR IN
LIGHT OF THE MANY L. A. TIMES
ARE MANY US ON EVERY THIS THAT
IS JUST GOING INTO THE CULT OF
MUCH PAUL. THEY DO NOT TELL THE
WHOLE STORY BECAUSE SIMPLY KILL
BACK THE CURTAIN ON TO EXPOSE
CULTURE OF COVER UPS CRIME
PROTECTION AS A FRIEND IN A BE.
TO BE CLEAR THESE ISSUES ARE
NOT ICE OR YOU KNOW TO ONE A WE
SEE THE ISSUES OF ACTOR AND
STRETCHING FROM THE FLOOR HIM
TO BE DEEP ON THE ERRORS ARE
BORDER TO THE M. OF THE DAY ARE
JUST ACROSS STREET AND SECOND.
NO OKAY IS IMMUNE FROM AXE AND
BAD ACTORS AND A HIGHLY IN
INTER IN DEFEAT YOU KNOW AND
INTO PROTECT SYSTEMS ARE BROKEN
WHEN SB SIXTY BY HATE WAS
PASSED IN NINETEEN COULD NOT BE
UNDER THE WAS ACTING IN GOOD
FAITH IT WAS BECAUSE OF THE OX
THE LEGISLATION WITH MUCH
NEEDED TO REFORMS TO THEM TO
GET BACK ON TRACK AND THAT IN
THE PUBLIC CENTER. BUT AS WITH
MANY OF ACCOUNT BE ACCOUNTED
MEASURE AND W. D. TRIED WE SB
SIXTY ARE THE YEARS. OFFICE
WHICH WE FOUGHT BACK. WITH
IMMENSE- ARM STRENGTH. SOMEONE
HAS WORKED FOR HIM TO BE OVER
TWENTY YEARS I'VE BEEN AROUND
AGENCY FOR. NEAR SINCE THE LATE
EIGHTIES I CAN TELL YOU. THIS
IS STANDARD PRACTICE BUT IT HAS
WORSENED OVER THE LAST TEN TO
FIFTEEN YEARS THIRTY SECONDS BE
FOUR EIGHTY AND TAKES THE RIGHT
APPROACH TO ENSURE MANAGEMENT
AND THE BOARD CANNOT SWEEP
CHANGES THE REFORMS AND WE CAN
THEM. HAS BEEN PRACTICE. IN
CLOSING I'LL JUST SAY. M. W. D.
NEEDS THESE REFORMS THE PUBLIC.
DESERVES THESE REFORMS. AND OUR
MEMBERS DESERVE TO WORK IN A
WORKPLACE FREE FROM HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION BOWLING IN
RETALIATION. THE BAD ACTORS
NEED TO BE CALLED OUT OF THE
SHADOWS AND THE VICTIMS SHOULD
BE ABLE TO COME FORWARD OUT OF
THE SHADOWS BE TREATED FAIRLY.
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT MY VOTE
ON FORTY AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THIS TIME THINK SO MUCH AS
YOU CAN AND RESEARCH AND HAND
IT WITH ASKED ME WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TO DATE WE
ARE NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO.
HEAR IN THIRTY ONE ANYONE IS
THERE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK. IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR EIGHTY.
HEARING SEE NO ONE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE. WE'RE
GONNA ASK OUR MODERATOR TO BE
ABLE TO QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO IS
IN SUPPORT. OF SB FOUR EIGHTY
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
DO SO NOW. CERTAINLY THANK YOU
SO ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR EIGHTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE. FOLLOWED BY
ZERO NOW. FIRST WE GO TO LINE
OF NINE TO. WHICH AGAIN NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS PRESS
FORTY DOLLARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE EIGHTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS ONE
INTRO AND THE MOTHERS OUT FRONT
TO A COMPELLING IN A REPORT. WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU CALLING
IN TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE NO FURTHER LINE
SECURED FOR SUPPORT MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT MISTER
MODERATOR WE APPRECIATE THAT
THAT LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE DOING. THE ROUND
ROBIN ON ALL ISSUES OF
OPPOSITION. WE'RE GOING TO
START HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE TO GO TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
BE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION A
FORTY. HEARING SEEING NO ONE
STAND WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING
TO OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE
MODERATOR MR MODERATOR IF YOU
DON'T MIND. ASK FOLKS TO BE
ABLE TO QUEUE UP IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FOUR EIGHTY THE FLOOR IS
YOURS MISTER MODERATOR.
CERTAINLY THANK YOU SO ONCE
AGAIN TO QUEUE UP IN
OPPOSITION. OR SB FOUR EIGHTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO NOW FOR US. AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO BLIND KILLING BY
PHONE. ALL RIGHT MISTER
MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE I DO WE HAVE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE OR MOTION. A POLICE
AS CENTER NIELSEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN LITTLE BIT OF
REFLECTION ON MY FATHER WATER
DISTRICT. FOR THOSE OF US IN
THE NORTH WE LONG HAD AN
ANTAGONISTIC RELATIONSHIP WITH
M. W. D. STARTED FOR ME WITH
SOMETHING CALLED APPROVAL CANAL
THAT WAS PROMOTED BY FIRST TIME
AROUND GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN.
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THAT THE
KIND OF CURIOUS TURN THAT THIS
TOOK AND IT DOES HAVE RELEVANCE
TO WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
RIGHT NOW I'M NOT JUST
REFLECTING ON THE PAST. I GOT A
CALL FROM THE CHIEF OF STAFF
FOR GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA THE
WANTING TO. SECURE MY SUPPORT
FOR AND A HIGH LEVEL AND THEY
WOULD BE OFFICIAL MISTER DAVID
KENNEDY TO BECOME THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES. WELL MY HACKLES
IMMEDIATELY ROLLERS ON MY NECK
AND I SAID. NOT KNOW BUT HAD NO.
AND HE SAID WELL JIM YOU DON'T
EVEN KNOW THEM AND WOULD YOU BE
WILLING TO MEET AND TALK WITH
HIM. AND I SAID OF COURSE AND I
DID. AND I FOUND IT TO BE AN
EXTRAORDINARILY REASONABLE MAN
THE LEADER AND ONE WHO COULD
GET BEYOND WHATEVER HAD BEEN
HIS PAST AND LOOK FOR THE GOOD
OF THE STATE AND ONE OF OUR
BEST DEPARTMENT DIRECTORS THAT
LED EVER DEALT WITH. SHOW THAT
WOULD LEAD TO THE POINT THAT
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN AND WD CAN
BE VERY CAPABLE AND VERY
HELPFUL. AND SO I TAKE THAT
INTO ACCOUNT AS WE DEAL WITH
THIS CURRENT SITUATION
OBVIOUSLY PERSONALLY I'M NOT
VERY FAMILIAR WITH OTHER THAN
THE STORIES. BUT THIS IS A VERY
TROUBLED AGENCY. AND IT DOES
WARRANT THE ATTENTION THAT
OFFENDER STERN IS GOING TO.
COST TO COME UPON THAT AGENCY
IT DOES NEED IT. I WISH WE
COULD DO SIMILAR THINGS FOR
SOME OF OUR STATE DEPARTMENT AS
WELL THAT ARE OUT OF CONTROL.
THE PARTICULAR ET DATE BUT THAT
SAID I THINK THAT THERE IS SOME
HOPE HERE IN THIS NAY INITIATE
A PROCESS WHERE WE CAN HELP
THAT DISTRICT. GET ON ITS FEET
AND BE CREDIBLE AGAIN.
ATTENTIVE TO ITS PERSONNEL AND
ITS POLICIES AND RESPECTED
INSTEAD OF CREATING CHAOS SO
I'M HOPEFUL THIS LEGISLATION
WILL BE A POSITIVE STEP MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND I JUST BE GRANTED
JACK THAT'S TO SAY THAT THE-
HISTORY CAN BE PRELUDE AND THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN TIMES WHEN
THINGS HAVE HAPPENED THAT
DIDN'T WORK OUT. AND MAYBE JUST
GET INTO THANK YOU SO MUCH A
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT- THOSE
WORDS OF CENTER NIELSEN MISTER
VICE CHAIR I CENTER DRUGS OF
THE FOR SERVICE PLEASE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AS BEFORE EIGHTY-
OBVIOUSLY THESE ARE THE KINDS
OF THINGS AND ACTIONS WHETHER
IT'S BY INDIVIDUALS OR OR- YOU
KNOW ONE INDIVIDUAL OR MANY
INDIVIDUALS THAT IS OF VERY
BOTHERSOME- IT SOUNDS LIKE IT
TOOK. A WHILE FOR THAT TO
BECOME UNFORTUNATELY MORE OF
THE CULTURE THAN AN EXCEPTION
TO THE RULE SO I SUPPORTERS
BEFORE EIGHTY. MY HOPE IS THAT
THROUGH AS BEFORE EIGHTY
THROUGH THAT- INDEPENDENT AUDIT
THAT M. W. D. HAS ALL CALLED
FOR TO HAVE- TO HELP THEM. AND
OF BY THE AUDIT- THAT HAS BEEN
CALLED FOR THAT THE COMBINATION
OF THOSE REALLY ESTABLISHED-
THE RULES BY WHICH THEY WILL
BEGIN TO CHANGE THEIR CULTURE.
AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
JUST HAPPENS OVERNIGHT AND SO I
AM MOST HOPEFUL UP AFTER IS
BEFORE EIGHTY IS APPROVED AND
SIGNED INTO LAW. THAT THAT
WOULD BE ENOUGH FOR THEM TO BE
THE TO TAKE IT SO SERIOUS THAT
THEY IN FACT IMPLEMENT CHANGES
FROM THE TOP STARTING FROM THE
TOP ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE
ORGANIZATION BECAUSE- THAT'S
THE ONLY WAY THINGS ARE GOING
TO CHANGE THEIR SELF- THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR. AND THANK YOU TO
M. W. D. FOR THE ROLE THAT
THEY'RE PLAYING AND TO ASK ME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER DRIVE
SO ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS AT FROM THE COMMITTEE
HEARING IN SEEN NINE IS THERE A
MOTION TO APPROVE. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY CENTER DRAWS ON THE
FLOOR MOTION BY SENATOR RISING.
WE'RE GONNA TURN OVER DINNER
STERN TO CLOSE PLEASE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ALL
RIGHT- SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
CENTER DRAWS- MISTER NOW CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE FORMA
MOTION IN CALL VOTE. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI MCGUIRE HI SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI SENATOR DORADO.
DORADO HI SENATOR HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE SENATOR WIENER.
FOUR ZERO IT'S CURRENTLY FOUR
ZERO VOTE LAZY JENNA COMMITTEE
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT BILL ON
CALL IN CENTER WIENER IS
CURRENTLY CHAIRING HOUSING HE
WILL BE HERE AROUND NINE PM SO-
THE WAY THAT KID I COMMITTEES
GOING AT THIS POINT SO I LAYS
IN GERMAN I WE ARE NOT GOING TO
BE MOVING NOW TO THE MAN THE
MYTH THE LEGEND FROM PASADENA
HIS NAME IS CENTER PORTANTINO
HE IS GONNA BE PRESENT TíNH
ITEM NUMBER FIVE THIS IS REALLY
A CRITICAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. SB FORTY FIVE
WHICH IS THE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION SAFE DRINKING WATER
DROP PREPARATION IN FLOOD
PROTECTION BOND AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY TWO HE'S WORKING IN
CONNECTION WITH OF COURSE
SENATOR STERN SENATOR ALLEN AND
MANY OTHER MEMBERS AT THE
SENATE THAT SENATE PORTANTINO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR IMPORTANT
WORK ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS ON SB FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU- MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AS MENTIONED TO THEM
PRESENTING SB FORTY FIVE-
CALIFORNIA'S EXPERIENCE THE
IMPACTS OF A CLIMATE EMERGENCY-
WE NOW HAVE ETERNALFIRE
SEASONS WATER SHORTAGES AND
INCREASED DROUGHT MORE SEVERE
FLOODING AND ESCALATING NUMBERS
OF EXTREME HEAT DAYS THAT BUT
OUR RESIDENTS AND OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AT RISK THESE
EVENTS ARE ALREADY COSTING
CALIFORNIA BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
A YEAR WE MUST TAKE BOLD ACTION
NOW TO FUND CLIMATE RESILIENCY
AND MITIGATE CLIMATE DISASTERS
THAT LOOM AHEAD IF WE ARE AND
IF WE DO NOT ACT NOW. TODAY I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND SB
FORTY FIVE THE WILDFIRE SAFE
DRINKING WATER DROUGHT
PREPARATION AND FLOOD
PROTECTION BY AN ACTIVE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WHICH WILL PUT A
BALLOT MEASURE BEFORE THE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS TO FIND THE
SOLUTIONS WE DESPERATELY NEED
THAT CALIFORNIA FROM FOR THE
RAVAGES OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
RECORD SETTING WILDFIRES ARE
BEING FUELED BY CLIMATE DRIVEN
DROUGHT AND INCREASED
TEMPERATURES AND THE CLIMATE
WILDFIRE FEEDBACK LOOP TRIGGERS
MORE MASSIVE AND MORE FREQUENT
WILDFIRES THESE EXTRA FIRESTOP
MILLIONS OF TONS OF MORE
GREENHOUSE GAS INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE. AND WIPE OUT
HARBANS REQUEST DURATION SIX.
FAR WARPING THE PRAGUE CAL MAY
REDUCING EMISSIONS VEHICLES AND
THE SECTOR. MORE THAN FOUR
POINT TWO MILLION ACRES BURNED
IN TWENTY TWENTY AND THE LAST
FOUR YEARS CALIFORNIA FIRES
KILLED A HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
PEOPLE. ARE TRAGICALLY
DESTROYED FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
STRUCTURES AND POLLUTED THE AIR
FOR MILLION. HISTORICALLY OUR
STATE FRESH DRINKING WATER
COMES FROM THE SLOW TRICKLE OF
MELTING SNOW. RECHARGING OUR
GROUNDWATER BASIN THIS YEAR
ROUND FRESH WATER SUPPLY HOLDS
US INTO THE DRYERS BUT CLIMATE
DRIVEN SEVERE DROP COUPLED WITH
SOME OF THE HOTTEST YEARS EVER.
RECORDED IS RISKING OUR
ECONOMIC STRENGTH. BY DEPLETING
OUR SNOW PACK. THE STATE IS
INVESTING LESS THAN HALF OF
WHAT IT NEEDS. TO PROPERLY
ADDRESS THE GROWING DIVIDE RISK
FROM FREQUENT ATMOSPHERIC RIVER
RAINSTORMS THE STATE CURRENTLY
HAS SOME TWO FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF BUILDINGS. SUSCEPTIBLE
TO FLOODING AND 20% OF THE
STATE'S POPULATION ALREADY
LIVES IN A FLOOD PRONE AREAS.
WE ALSO NEED TO MITIGATE THE
EFFECTS OF SEA LEVEL RISE TO
PREVENT THE INTRUSION OF SALT
INTO OUR GROUNDWATER AND
SAFEGUARD NEARLY HALF A MILLION
SUSCEPTIBLE RESIDENTS. A
HUNDRED FIFTY BILLION IN
PROPERTY AND THREE THIRTY FIVE.
HUNDRED MILES OF ROADS. SB
FORTY FIVE PROPOSES A GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND TO INJECT THIS
REVENUE TO ADDRESS THESE
IMPACTS. THE MEASURE PROPOSES
TO FIND REDUCE FIRE RISK AND
RESTORE AREAS THAT ARE ALREADY
DAMAGE RESTORE PROTECT IMPACTED
WETLANDS WATERSHEDS IN
MODERATION. REDUCE IMPACTS ON
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IMPROVE
THE RESILIENCY OF OUR WATER
SUPPLY AGRICULTURAL LAND. ON
THE PHONE WITH ME TODAY WE HAVE
ADRIAN COVERT OF POLICY MANAGER
FOR THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
INTIMATE WORDS PRESIDENT OF CAL
FIRE LOCAL. TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
ONE AND I WAS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. THANK YOU SOME-
SENATOR. WERE GREAT. LADIES AND
GONNA GO TOWARD TO LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES. EACH WITNESS ONE
THREE MINUTES AND WE'RE GONNA
GIVE YOU A THIRTY SECOND PROMPT
AS YOU GET CLOSE TO THAT THREE
MINUTES. LET'S START WITH MR
COVERED. WHO IS THE POLICY
MAJOR DAIRY COUNCIL MISTER
COVERT YOU HAVE THE FLOOR SIR
YOU ARE CURRENTLY IN COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND SENATOR
PORTANTINO ON BEHALF OF THE
LARGEST EMPLOYERS IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA BAY AREA
COUNCILS PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB
FORTY FIVE IN RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I. ABOUT. WITHIN
THE PAST SEVEN YEARS
CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY VOLATILE
CLIMATE HAS SHATTERED
LONGSTANDING CLIMATE RECORDS
RELATED TO DROUGHT. WILDFIRES
HEAT AND FLOODS. THESE
DISASTERS DAMAGE ECOSYSTEMS DAY
HURT ECONOMIES AND THEY DISRUPT
AND TOO OFTEN TRAGICALLY COST
HUMAN LIVES. THE TWENTY TWELVE
TO TWENTY SIXTEEN DROUGHT ALONE
COST THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC LOSSES AND
NEARLY THIRTY THOUSAND JOBS.
THAT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WILDFIRES ALONE THAT YEAR COSTS
NEARLY A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN LOSSES. AND
TRAGICALLY A HUNDRED THIRTY ONE
HUNDRED THREE DEATHS. IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE FLOODS COST.
SEVENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
IN LOSSES IN SAN JOSE ALONE AND
NEARLY TOPPLED YOUR GOAL DOWN
EMERGENCY SPILLWAY. AND THEN OF
COURSE JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO IN
AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY IT WAS THE
HOTTEST MONTH IN STATE HISTORY.
EXTREME HEAT IS CAUSING
INCREASED PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHOP EVENTS ROLLING BLACKOUTS
AND APPROXIMATELY FORTY DEATHS
EACH YEAR. SB FORTY FIVE WOULD
ASK VOTERS TO INVEST FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS TO UPGRADE AND
IMPROVE RESILIENCE OF
CALIFORNIA'S NEIGHBORHOODS
BUSINESSES. INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ECOSYSTEMS TO THESE AND OTHER
CLIMATE RELATED CHALLENGES AND
IN DOING SO. SB FORTY FIVE WILL
NOT ONLY HEP SAVE LIVES AND
AVOID COSTLY DAMAGES FROM
CLIMATE RELATED DISASTERS. BUT
WOULD ALSO HELP CREATE JOBS
STIMULATE GROWTH IMPROVE
ECONOMIC- ECOSYSTEM HEALTH AND
PROTECT COMMUNITIES THIRTY
SEVEN ALICE'S THAT WE DID AT
THE BAY AREA COUNCIL- LAST YEAR
SHOWS WITH A BOND OF. A SIMILAR
SIZE AND STRUCTURE AS SB. FORTY
FIVE WOULD CREATE A PROPER
ASSEMBLY SAID FIVE DOLLAR JOB
GENERATE NINE POINT BILL
DOLLARS IN TOTAL ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY. ACROSS CALIFORNIA- TO
WORK TO STRENGTHEN THEIR
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT IS AN
AMERICAN TRADITION GOING BACK
TO THE NEW DEAL AND THE MOST
RECENT POLLING SHOWS A STRONG
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS WITH
SUPPORT OF CLIMATE RESILIENCE
BONTA HI THE JOB CREATION.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING MY
COMMENTS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. THAT'S A DOING
COVERED FROM THE VERY COUNCIL
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS COVERED
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO
OUR SECOND AND FINAL LEAD
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE THAT'S PETE
MIGNON HE'S THE GENERAL VICE
PRESIDENT FOR CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY ONE. MR MENU ARE YOU
MISTER MANUAL WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS. AND
I AM THE GENERAL VICE PRESIDENT
OF CAL FIRE FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL
TWENTY EIGHTY ONE. THIS TORRENT
FIRE THIS PAST THREE YEARS ARE
A MATTER OF RECORD. THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS SPENT
CONSIDERABLE TIME ENERGY
INSIGHT IN PREPARING CALIFORNIA
REQUIRES THAT HAVE GROWN IN
MAGNITUDE AND CONSEQUENCE.
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS ARE PROUD
TO WORK IN TANDEM WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL PARTNERS IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FIVE BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO. I WILL BE
BRIEF THE LADY. WILLIAMS OVER
TIME. THANKS IN THE WORKING AND
IT'S BUT USUALLY A TWENTY FOUR
HOUR DAY ARE USUALLY OFF SITE
THEN GO BACK TO FIGHTING FIRES.
MANY OF OUR FIREFIGHTERS HAVE
HAD TO NOT HAD A COMPLETE SHIFT
OFF OF WORK SINCE JULY TWENTY
TWENTY. FIREFIGHTERS ARE AT THE
EPICENTER OF DISASTERS AT A
TIME WHEN THEY MEET YOU AND
NINETY SIX HOUR SHIFTS ARE NOT
UNCOMMON. A LITTLE EMOTIONAL
CHALLENGES ARE PROFOUND.
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN AGGRESSIVE
IN PUTTING TOGETHER
INFRASTRUCTURE OF PREPARATION
REQUIRES HOWEVER AND A TIME
WITH 90% OF THE STATE AND THE
90% OF THE STATE IS GOING TO BE
IN DROUGHT CONDITIONS AND
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE CHANGE AND
GROW DEMOGRAPHICS A
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR TO THIS
CRISIS. THERE IS MUCH MORE THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE. WILDCARD THEY
DRINKING WATER GROCKA SHIN AND
LEPPERT ACTION BOND OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THE SIGNIFICANT STEP
IN PRIORITIZING OUR BATTLE
AGAINST FIRE DISASTER. WE ARE
PRETTY APPRECIATIVE OF SENATOR
PORTANTINO INSURANCE BILL THAT
WILL RESULT IN PROTECTING
PROPERTY AND SAVING LIVES. WE
ARE ALSO APPRECIATION OF
CHILDREN MCGUIRE WHO SO
ELOQUENTLY IN CALIFORNIA THE
GOLD STANDARD OF EMERGENCY
RESPONSE. THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
IT TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY IF
YOU ARE JOB. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
REVIVAL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THIS VICE PRESIDENT THANK
YOU OF FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK AND
PLEASE PASS ON OUR SINCERE
THANKS TO THE FIFTY FOUR
HUNDRED AND GROWING MEMBERS OF
LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE
IN FOR ALL OF YOUR EFFORTS ARE
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
SEEN IF WE HAVE A IN PERSON
TESTIMONY WE DO- COMING HERE IN
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE WE
WELCOME YOU SIR WELCOME BACK TO
COMMITTEE IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
FIRST CLASS ORGANIZATION IN
YOUR STANCE ON AS P. FORTY
FIVE. MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH JUST WEST
GOOD TO SEE YOU WE'RE GONNA SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT. OF SB. FORTY FIVE HERE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE.
HEARING SEEING NO ONE WE'RE NOT
TO BE CHECKING IN WITH THE MY-
WE'RE GOING BE GOING TO OUR-
LIVE TELE. LINE IF YOU'D LIKE
TO PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S
HEARING ON A TELECONFERENCE
LINE. DIAL TOLL FREE ANY TIME
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. THREE THREE
SIX FOUR FOUR THREE SIX. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
YOU ALL RIGHT MISTER MODERATOR.
LETS YOU FOLKS UP TO SB FORTY
FIVE THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT.
MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE
NOW. THANK YOU THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW FOR US.
FIRST WE ARE ALIGNED NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD MORNING THIS IS THE BALK
ON BEHALF OF THE CALGARY TOWER
LIGHTS WERE AWESOME SUPPORTER
SB FORTY FIVE ENTERED YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT WE ALIGN TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
KIM JONES STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR
AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH CAM
GOOD TO HEAR VOICES GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. NEXT WE HAVE A
LINE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TERM
ACQUIRE AND MEMBERS STEVEN
MYERS ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY
NATURE CONNECTION BUT NOT SLOW
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT
SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
HABITAT CONSERVATION PLANNING
COALITION ALL IN SUPPORT IF
AMENDED AS DETAILED IN THEIR
SUBMITTED LETTERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER MYERS NEXT
CALL PLEASE. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS OF MY
BETTER LUCK WITH THE WIDENING
GROUP ON BEHALF OF BLOOM ENERGY
INTO COURT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT OVER THE LINE
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON GAMES THEREAFTER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL LABORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
CALLING JAMES NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT WE HAVE LINE ONE
ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MARKS MAPS MY POLICY GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION THAT
GRASSLAND WATER DISTRICT IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA GUIDE
SPORTSMEN'S ASSOCIATION THAT
COASTAL CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA ALL
IN SUPPORT BUT STILL SEEKING
AMENDMENT AS IDENTIFIED IN THE
LETTERS WE HAVE MET IT THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
SMITH. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT WE HAVE ONE ONE
ZERO SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS EVELYN PUNISHED WITH
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
INSTRUCTOR PART OF THAT THE
45 DEGREES THANKS AND-
PORTANTINO FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO GO
TO LINE ONE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JAMIE MINOR ON
BEHALF OF THAT DE ID TO LIKE
YOUR NATION DISTRICT EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN A
MURDER READ A WATER DISTRICT
AND THE EMAIL IN CLEAN ENERGY
IN SUPPORT IN THE AMENDED
POSITION THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH JAMIE COULD
YOU HEAR VOICE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING RICHARD
MEMBERS ASKING HONEST ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES WE
ALSO HAVE A SUPPORT AMENDED
POSITION ON SB FORTY FIVE I
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD ALLOCATE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR WATER
RESILIENCE THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL HERE
COMMONSENSE GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. LINE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GET OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FRIEDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU CATHERINE. LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT WE
HAVE NINE ONE ZERO SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER FROM
YELP AND MARK MAR ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF MARIN IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU HEY THANK YOU SO MUCH
COOPER. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT WE HAVE ONE ONE ZERO NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHEN THE
REYNOLDS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ADVISORS VIDEO
SACRAMENTO ISN'T SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
PHONE CALL ALL RIGHT A SMARTER
THIS CHECK IN WITH OUR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT WE HAVE LINE FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER THIS IS
ERIN EVAN ON BEHALF OF THE TREE
CARE INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE IMPORTANT BELT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
EVANS GIVE OUR BEST YOUR MOM
THANK YOU SO MUCH OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANKS NEXT WE
HAVE LINE TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU- GOOD
MORNING POSH AND THURMOND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF LAND TRUSTS.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT.
THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN
SPACE THAT'S ALREADY A BIG STAR
LAND TRUST AND THE BOTH THE G.
KELANTAN ALL OF THE COURT THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE ZERO
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN NUMBERS MY NAME
IS DO CLEANING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BASED APART COUNCIL
MOUNTAINS RECREATION AND
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY
PENINSULA OPEN SPACE TRUST
PLASTER COUNTY AND- WILD AND
CONSERVANCY ALWAYS SUPPORT
THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE
CALL TODAY THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE ZERO TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
DEMAND MILLER CALLING ON BEHALF
OF UCLA SUSTAINABLE LA GRAND
CHALLENGE WE'RE CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FIVE
HOWEVER WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
SEVERAL AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED
IN THEIR LETTER THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
CALL TODAY THAT'S GO TO OUR
NEXT. CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE
HAVE ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
VERSACE'S JENNIFER FEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUSEUMS WE ARE
SUPPORTERS AMENDED IS AT THE
FORTY FIVE COULD INCLUDE
FUNDING TO PROTECT CULTURAL AND
HISTORIC RESOURCES FROM CLIMATE
IMPACTS AS DETAILED IN OUR
LETTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU I ALWAYS LOVE HEARING
FROM HEARING THANK YOU SO MUCH
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
NEXT WE HAVE A ONE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
KAREN MEMBER ASHLEY WALKER WITH
NOTHING ON BEHALF OF THE
MONTEREY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT AND
REQUESTING AN AMENDMENT TO
INCLUDE DAM SAFETY FUNDING
THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH
ACTUALLY APPRECIATED. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE NO FOR
THE COLORS IN SUPPORT MISTER
CHAIR MISTER MODERATOR NICE
WORK WILL BE BACK WITH YOU HERE
IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE SEEN IF THERE IS
ANYONE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK AGAINST IN OPPOSITION. OF
SB FORTY FIVE. HEARING SEEN
KNOWN EARLY CHECK BACK WITH THE
MODERATOR MODERATOR IS BUSY ON
SB FORTY FIVE HERE LASING
GENTLEMAN MR MODERATOR THAT'S
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FORTY FIVE
NOW. CERTAINLY ONCE AGAIN IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW FOR US.
ONE REMIND FOLKS IF YOU'D LIKE
TO PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S
HEARING THE PHONE NUMBER IS.
877-336-4436 MISTER MODERATOR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. AND AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE COULD OPEN
OPPOSITION MISTER CHAIR NICE
WORK MR MODERATOR THAT'S BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE CHECK IN
WITH COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
WILL ALSO WELCOME A MOTION. A
PLEASE MR VICE YEAR. THURMOND
JESSICA OFFERING THE WORDS OF
CAUTION AND CONCERN. THIS IS A
MAJOR OBLIGATION THE TAXPAYERS
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
HAVE A VERY PROBLEMATIC
SITUATION OF THE BONDED
INDEBTEDNESS OCCURRED OVER
DECADES IN THE STATE. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT HAVE HAPPENED
AS MANY MORE IDEAS NOW OR
SEEKING FUNDING FROM BOND
SOURCES. THE DEBT ON THE
TAXPAYERS. AS THIS PARTICULAR
BILL IS CONCERNED IT'S AN AREA
WHERE I HAVE GREAT INTEREST AND
I THINK THERE'S MUCH IN THIS
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL. I TOO
WOULD THINK AMENDMENTS IN TERMS
OF HOW THINGS ARE APPROPRIATED
AND THERE'S A MEASURE. WHAT HAS
BEEN OF CONCERN TO ME OVER
DECADES OF BOTH FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AND FROM OUTSIDE
INTEREST HOW THESE THINGS GET
TO BE A BIG PORK BARREL BY YOUR
VOTE. KIND OF PROPOSITIONS. I'M
NOT ACCUSING US OF BEING SUCH
BUT IT HAS THE POTENTIAL. THE
POINT I WANT TO DO WELL ON
THOUGH. I'M TRYING TO
CONCEPTUALIZE A MATTER AND WAY
OR BY THE LEGISLATURE CAN
PROVIDE HAVE OVERSIGHT. OF HOW
THE EXPENDITURES OF THESE BOND
FUNDS. ARE BEING MADE SO THERE
CAN BE AN ACCOUNTABILITY
INSTEAD OF JUST THROWING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OUT THERE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS GO TO
CONSTRUCTIVE PURPOSES AND WITH
CONCRETE RESULTS. WE REALLY
DON'T HAVE THAT THE OVERSIGHT
IS MINOR IF ANY AT ALL.
ALTHOUGH I CREDIT THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE OF THE SENATE FOR
BEING UP MUCH MORE FASTIDIOUS
ABOUT. BEING ACCOUNTABLE
AGENCIES BEING ACCOUNTABLE
EXPENDITURES BEING ACCOUNTABLE
ON OVERSIGHT WE HAVE ACCEPTED
THAT AND IN OUR BUDGET
RESPONSIBILITIES ON THAT
COMMITTEE THAT'S GOOD. I'M
LOOKING FOR EVEN MORE AS WE
PROCEED WITH THE BOND MEASURES
MAY BE OTHERS THAT COME TO BEAR
TO THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
AREA AND I WOULD ARGUE IN TERMS
OF THE- GENERATE I'VE MET THEM
MANY GENERAL BOND IDEAS IT WILL
BE COMING FORWARD THIS WOULD BE
PROBABLY THE MOST IMPORTANT. TO
MAKE. AND I CERTAINLY WILL WORK
ON IT I'M JUST OFFERING THAT
WORD OF CAUTION THAT WE NEED TO
PAY A LOT OF ATTENTION TO WHAT
AND HOW QUICKLY WE PUT THESE
BONDS UP AND OUT. AND WE MAKE
THEM ACCOUNTABLE THAT THAT WE
REALLY CUT COPY SURE PURPOSES
RATHER THAN JUST THROWING MONEY
AT THINGS THANK YOU MR THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER VICE CHAIR
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO
CENTER PORTANTINO FOR RESPONSE
TO THE VICE CHAIR- AND THEN.
WILL OFFER- WILL LOOK TO SEE IF
AND NUMBER WOULD OFFER A
PROMOTION. ALL RIGHT TOLD ME TO
PRINT YOU KNOW IF YOU WANNA
RESPOND ADVICE YOUR PLEASE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AS-
THE DEAN OF THE SENATE COMMENTS
ARE VERY WELL TAKEN- AS YOU
HEARD. ON THE PHONE LINE MOST
OF THE- AND- WE'RE TRYING TO.
THIS BIGGER- AND WE'RE TRYING
TO HOLD THE LINE WE UNDERSTAND
THE BONDED INDEBTEDNESS
QUESTION WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE AND THEN THEY WOULD
GET A SIGNATURE FROM THE
GOVERNOR SO WE'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM BUT ALSO
KEEPING A WATCHFUL EYE ON OUR
FISCAL RESTRAINT- TO GOOD
PROBLEM TO HAVE THE PEOPLE WANT
MORE- AND CERTAINLY I'D LOVE TO
GIVE IT BUT- WE'RE TRYING TO BE
VERY PRUDENT IN OUR APPROACH.
THE SECOND THING IS A LOT OF
THE MONEY BEING PROGRAM IS
GONNA BE DONE THROUGH LOCAL
CONSERVANCIES AND REGIONAL
AGENCIES AGAIN THE IDEA IS TO
HAVE IT BE BOTTOM UP NOT TOP
DOWN AND BRING THAT INHERENT
ACCOUNTABILITY FROM THE
REGION'S BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW-
SENATOR EACH PART OF OUR STATE
IS DIFFERENT AND HAS A
DIFFERENT INFRASTRUCTURE AND
LEADERSHIP CAPACITY AND SO
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK ON A LOCAL
LEVEL TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS THAT. LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
AND- LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH. THANK YOU
SACRAMENTO. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER PORTANTINO I DO WE HAVE
A MOTION TO APPROVE. ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
ALSO SEND PORTANTINO LOOK AT
WHAT I REALLY APPRECIATE ABOUT
THIS BOND ONE- YOU ARE DOING
THIS RIGHT NOT FAST- WERNER
SECOND YEAR IN A DISCUSSION- ON
A BOND LIKE THIS. AND CENTER
PORTANTINO IS ONE OF THOSE.
MEMBERS THAT MEASURED IN HIS
APPROACH AT FOCUSING ON DATA
NOT JUST ON HEADLINES LOOKING
AT WHAT THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES THE STATE FACES IN
TRYING TO BE ABLE TO GO AFTER
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS IN VERY
GRATEFUL UP FOR THIS. I THINK
THE OTHER REALLY IMPORTANT
PIECE ABOUT THIS BOND- AS THE
VICE CHAIR OF BUDGET WHO IS
ALSO THE DEAN OF THE SENATE-
THE GOOD SENATOR. AT CENTER
NIELSEN HAS BEEN FOCUSING IN ON
HOW DO WE LOOK AT LONG TERM
FIRE PREVENTION FUNDING- AND
THIS IS PART OF A SIGNIFICANT
PART OF THE PUZZLE THE BILL
THAT LONG TERM PLAN TO TACKLE
ONE OF THE BIGGEST ISSUES.
FACING AT THIS STATE SO OUT
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO
CENTER PORTANTINO OUT FOR THE
CLOSING AGAIN THANKS FOR ALL
YOUR HARD WORK SIR WELL MISTER
MCGUIRE YOU GAVE A GREAT CLOSE
ALL STATE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. CERVANTINO TRULY
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR EFFORTS
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR EMOTIONAL
FOR BY CENTER DRIVE SO MR CANAL
IF YOU COULD PLEASE CALL THE
FORMAL FORMAL- MOTION IN
BECAUSE OF A- BUSH. IS DUE PASS.
BUT FIRST RE BE RE FOR TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN AYE
SENATOR DORADO. DORADO HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG RIGHT
HERTZBERG OUR SENATOR WIENER.
FOUR ZERO FOUR IS ZERO VOTE
LAZY GERMAN KEEP THAT BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
WIENER IS GOING TO BE HERE AT
MIDNIGHT- SO IT'S GOOD IT'S
GONE FROM NINE TO MIDNIGHT NOW
SELL THEIR DRUGS AS WITH ME ON
THAT ONE MY GOODNESS- SO- WE
ARE NOW MOVING INTO WE ARE-
INTO THE LUNCH HOUR HERE AT SO
WE WELCOME YOU TO THE LUNCH
HOUR ADDITION A GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE- WE AT SID HERE MARTHA
IS READY TO ROLL. WE'RE
BRINGING UP SOONER CORTESE
CENTER CORTESE THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM SAN JOSE HI THIS IS BEEN-
AN ISSUE THAT HE'S BEEN
DEDICATED ON HIS FIRST YEAR IN
THE SENATE AND THAT IS THE
BIGGEST ISSUE OF OUR TIME AND
THAT'S CAR AND THAT KIND OF
CHANGE THAT WE HE'S GOING
PRESENTING SB THIRTY TWO
FOCUSING ON BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION REQUIREMENTS.
MISTER CORTESE THANK YOU FOR
ALL OF YOUR HARD WORK. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR ON SB THIRTY
TWO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF
THE FUTURE. SENATORS AND-
PRESIDENT SB THIRTY TWO. OF
THE- DECARBONISATION OCT TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THE STATE-
RESOURCES BOARD FINDS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S BUILDING ENERGY
USE ACCOUNTS. FOR ALMOST 25%
FOR STATEWIDE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN-
FOR HIS BUILDING ENERGY USE.
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR DIRECTLY
EMITTING. THIRTY SEVEN MILLION
METRIC TONS OF GREENHOUSE
GASES. IT'S ESTIMATED. THE
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION. CAN
REDUCE TOTAL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN A SINGLE FAMILY
HOME. WHERE 3260% ON AVERAGE.
YEAH US CARBON EMISSIONS BY ONE
BILLION TONS ANNUALLY. BECAUSE
THE THIRD OF CALIFORNIA'S
TWENTY FORTY FIVE BUILDING
STOCK WILL BE BUILT BETWEEN NOW
AND TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
PRIORITIZING NEW CONSTRUCTION
THAT INCLUDES DECARBONISATION
TECHNOLOGIES IS KEY TO REACHING
THE STATE'S FOSSIL FUEL
REDUCTION TARGETS. TO
DECARBONISE THE BUILDING IS TO
REMOVE GHG EMISSIONS FROM
BUILDINGS ENERGY USE. AND I
DISTINGUISH THAT FROM THE
BUILDINGS CONSTRUCTION THE
USAGE OF ENERGY IN THE BUILDING
AND TO ENSURE THAT THE BUILDING
RELIES SOLELY ON RENEWABLE ZERO
EMISSION SOURCES FOR INSTANCE-
BY WAY OF EXAMPLE THROUGH
BUILDING ELECTRIFICATION OR
SOLAR ENERGY. I EMPHASIZE THAT.
BECAUSE YOU MAY HEAR TESTIMONY
TODAY IN CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. WITH A
REQUEST TO CLARIFY THAT THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL IS TO
DECARBONISE REMOVE CARBON FROM
THE BUILDING. A BUILDING'S
ENERGY USAGE. AND I'VE AGREED
TO FURTHER CLARIFY THAT TODAY-
WE THOUGHT THE BILL WAS CLEAR
IN THAT REGARD BUT SHOOT ANY
FURTHER CLARIFYING LANGUAGE BE
NEEDED IN THAT REGARD- THAT
THAT'S FINE WITH ME AS THE
AUTHOR- BY REMOVING CARBON FROM
OUR BUILDINGS ENERGY USE. WE
ARE TRANSITIONING ENERGY USE
FROM AGAIN BY WAY OF EXAMPLE
NATURAL GAS TO CARBON FREE
SOURCES SUCH AS ELECTRICITY OR
SOLAR. I'LL BE CLEAR FIND THE
BILL LANGUAGE- GOING FORWARD.
AS I JUST SAID TO ENSURE THAT
IT'S VERY CLEAR. THAT THE BILL
DOES NOT EXTEND TO BUILDING
MATERIAL FOR EXAMPLE- CARBON
FREE CEMENT HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED
AS A POTENTIAL. OF BUILDING
MATERIAL THAT MAY BE USEFUL IN
THIS CLIMATE CRISIS. WELL I
THINK OF THINGS LIKE THAT ARE
WORTHY PLACES. TO THINK ABOUT
REMOVING CARBON THIS BILL IS
NOT FOCUSED ON THAT THE
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON THE
ENERGY USAGE OF THE BUILDING.
TO ASSIST IN MUNICIPALITIES
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
STATE ENERGY EFFICIENCY TARGETS
SB THIRTY TWO REQUIRES CITIES
AND COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA TO
MAKE A ONE TIME UPDATE. TO
EITHER THEIR LOCAL GENERAL PLAN
DURING THE NEXT UPDATE CYCLE
ORDER CLIMATE ACTION PLAN
DURING ITS NOT NEXT UPDATE
CYCLE. OR BUILDING CODE DURING
ITS NEXT UPDATE CYCLE WITH
OBJECTIVES TARGETS AND POLICIES
A SPECIFIED TO DECARBONISE
NEWLY CONSTRUCTED BUILDINGS IN
LINE WITH THE- PARVIS. ALMOST
MOVE SERVED IN LOCAL AND
REGIONAL GOVERNMENT AND
INTERACTED WITH LOCAL AND
REGIONAL GOVERNMENT PLANNING
PROCESSES INCLUDING THE SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE PROCESS NO-
THE TARGETS IN POLICIES ON THE
PLANNING SIDE TYPICALLY GO IN A
LOCAL GENERAL PLAN OF CLIMATE
RELATED IN THE CLIMATE ACTION
PLAN. BILL REQUESTED THE UPDATE
INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING REPORT
ON GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
DATA FOR EXISTING COMMERCIAL
RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS. A
SUMMARY OF LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL POLICIES PROGRAMS AND
REGULATIONS. THAT WE A SYSTEM
DECARBONISATION OF EXISTING AND
NEWLY CONSTRUCTED COMMERCIAL
RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS. IN A
COMPREHENSIVE SET OF FEASIBLE
IMPLEMENTATION STRATEGIES TO
DECARBONISE NEW CONSTRUCTION
COMMERCIAL RESIDENTIAL
BUILDINGS CONSISTENT WITH THE
STATE'S EMISSION REDUCTION
BUILDING ENERGY EFFICIENT
TARGETS. THE URGENCY OF OUR
CLIMATE CRISIS DEMANDS ACTION.
CITIES COUNTIES IN THE STATE
MUST MAKE A JOINT EFFORT
DECARBONIZE OUR BUILDING STOCK
FOR TO MEET THE STATE'S
AMBITIOUS GOALS. IT'S IMPORTANT
THESE UPDATES REFLECTED IN THE
LOCALS PLANNING THE DOCUMENTS
SUCH AS THE- EVENTUALLY
REFLECTED IN REGIONAL PLANNING
DOCUMENTS BUT IN THE BAY AREA
FOR EXAMPLE.THE PLAN BAY AREA
IS A DOCUMENT THAT'S REQUIRED.
UNDER S. B. THREE SEVENTY FIVE.
WELL IT WAS REQUIRED IN EVERY
OTHER REGION IN THE STATE IN
ORDER TO INFORM THE STATE. HOW
REGIONS IN THOSE CITIES AND
COUNTIES IN THEIR GENERAL PLANS
IN THE PLANNING PROCESS IS
INTENDED TO REACH GHG REDUCTION
TARGETS. CURRENTLY REGIONAL
PLANS REQUIRE THE INTERNET
SPEED THREE SEVENTY FIVE. BUT
THERE'S NO LEGISLATIVE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE GENERAL
PRINCIPLES REGIONAL PLANS ARE
BASED ON. A CONTAINER SEEM
INFORMATION. THIS BILL WOULD
HELP CITIES AND COUNTIES.
RESTATE TARGETS INFORM STATE
TARGETS IN A FORM OF COURSE THE
REGIONAL TARGETS OF FEET IN THE
STATE TARGETS. BY SERVING AS A
CATALYST FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES. TO EXCEED STATE
ENERGY THE CURRENT TARGETS BUT
IF WE WISH- BUT IN ANY CASE TO
DISCLOSE WHAT THEIR TARGETS
ARE. I'D LIKE TO NOTE THAT I'VE
SUBMITTED OFFER MEMBERS FOR
THIS BILL ALL THESE LIMITS WERE
FORMED. WITH INPUT. WELL FROM
NUMERO LOCAL ORDERS K. YOU
MEMBERS EXPAND THE FOLKS
BILLION OPTIONS AVAILABLE FOR
LOCALS TO MAKE UPDATES
SPECIFIED IN THIS BILL. THE
BILL WAS AMENDED FROM ASKING
FOR THESE SPECIFIC UP THE
SENATE GENERAL PLAN. TO
ALLOWING LOCALS TO MAKE A ONE
TIME ABOUT THE- TO EITHER THEIR
LOCAL GENERAL PLAN DURING THIS
NEXT UPDATE CYCLE. CLIMATE
ACTION PLAN DURING ITS NEXT IT
UPDATE CYCLE WE'RE BUILDING
CODE DURING ITS NET NEXT UPDATE
CYCLE WITH THE REQUESTED
OBJECTIVES TARGETS AND POLICIES.
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL INCLUDE
THE SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA. THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION VOTERS
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION THE CLIMATE CENTER
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS AND DOZENS OF
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS. ACROSS THE
STATE IS A LONG LONG LIST OF.
SUPPORT VOTERS SO IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL- AND I KNOW YOU HAVE
THE ANALYSIS WITH US TODAY IS
WARM COLD FROM THE SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
ILLUZZI NICKERSON FROM
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA ALSO TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IN THE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR WHOLE. THAT'S CENTER
CORTESE HONESTY THIRTY TWO
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
SENATOR ALL RIGHT HERE WE GO
LET'S GO TO OUR LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES WE'VE TO WE'RE GONNA
START OUT WITH LAUREN COLUMN
WITH AT THE SIERRA CLUB OF
CALIFORNIA LAUREN WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES I'M GONNA GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU. I'M GOOD MORE OR GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MORNING CALL ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA. REPRESENTING HALF A
MILLION MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS
ACROSS THE STATE. YOUR CALL
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTS SB THIRTY
TWO WHICH WOULD REQUIRE CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO CONSIDER POLICY
PROGRAMS AND STRATEGY. TO
DECARBONISE THE NEWLY
CONSTRUCTED BUILDING.
DECARBONIZATION OF CALIFORNIANS
HOMES AND BUILDINGS IT'S NOT
ONLY THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
CUT CLIMATE POLLUTION. BUT
DOING SO CAN REDUCE AIR
POLLUTION BENEFIT PUBLIC
HEALTH. REDUCE CONSTRUCTION
COSTS AND CREATE JOBS. NOT EVEN
ACTUALLY SHOW ALL OF YOUR CALL
ARE HOPE YOU'RE THREE. THE
ENHANCED INDOOR AND OUTDOOR AIR
QUALITY REDUCE SAFETY RISKS
ESPECIALLY THE CAST AND CREW
PUBLIC HEALTH. IMPACT OF REVIEW
PREPARED BY UCLA RESEARCHERS
ESTIMATED THAT ELIMINATING THE
AIR POLLUTION FROM JUST
CATHOLIC FINE THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA HOME. THREE THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR LIVE ON
THREE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS. TO HELP US IN YOUR- IN
ADDITION BECAUSE BUILD ARE
CHEAP TO BUILD OPERATE. FOR
GOING BACK WITHOUT AND APPLYING
PEOPLE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
CONSTRUCTION COSTS AND MOVING
TO A TO COME. THE BUILDINGS AND
MAKE OKAY MORE. ALTHOUGH MUCH
OF MINOR DON'T DEPARTMENT ADDED
BEEN OF CREATION AT THE NEW
DEMAND BILL. FOR LASTLY WE
NEVER INFOGRAPHIC CLIMATE
CHANGE. THE PUNISHMENT. AND AS
IF THAT WAS THE- ONE WITH THE
BILL INSPECTOR COUNTING ABOUT
TWO FIVE PER. OVER WIDE
REMARKED MEASURE. IT IS SIMPLY
NOT. FOR HIT OUR- TARGETS FOR
FEELING DIFFERENT. LEFT HOME.
BUT BONNIE BUILDING BECAUSE-
WARLOCK THAT THEY THAT THE
CHRONICLE. AND COULD CAUSE
CALIFORNIA. OF IN YORK I'M NOT.
GAP OF THE STAR. WILL BE A- AS
LEGGED. NOTHING OVER NEXT
TWENTY YEARS. SB TO THE COULD
BUILT MEASURE. REACHES THE- AND
AIR QUALITY GOAL. HERE BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA MIGHT BE THANKS THE
COCKLES FOR GREEN ON PART YOU.
A BUILDING INSPECTOR AND- THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ABOUT. IT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH IS
GONE WE- THANKS FOR CALLING IN
TODAY WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
LIZZY NICKERSON. I MISS
DICKERSON IS THE FINAL. SUPPORT
WITNESS IN THE LEAD CATEGORY I
MISS NICKERSON YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT THE FLOOR.
IS YOURS YOU ARE NOW IN
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS LIVING A SAID AND IT IS
MY PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENT. IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY TWO- FIRST
I'D LIKE TO THANK SENATOR QUITE
HEAVY FOR INTRODUCING THIS BELT
THAT FALLS IN LINE WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA. MISSION
TO ADVANCE POLICIES. THAT
PROMOTE CLEAN ENERGY AND REDUCE
EMISSIONS TO FIGHT CLIMATE
CHANGE. CALIFORNIA IS OFTEN
LEADING THE NATION IN THE WORLD
ON CLIMATE POLICY BUT FOR
CALIFORNIA TO REMAIN A GLOBAL
LEADER FACED OF OUR CLIMATE
CRISIS. WE MUST FOCUS OUR
ATTENTION ON THE ENERGY USED IN
OUR BUILDING. CALIFORNIA HAS
OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
MILES OF GAS PIPELINES ACROSS
OUR STATE. THE COST OF GAS
MAINTENANCE IS ON THE RISE AND
THE GAS SYSTEM CAN POSE SERIOUS
HEALTH AND SAFETY RISK. IT HAS
NEVER BEEN EASIER TO MAKE OUR
HOMES AND BUILDINGS ALSO FEEL
FREE IN CALIFORNIA. AND IT'S
TIME TO GET RID OF DIRTY
DANGEROUS TECHNOLOGIES SWAP
THEM OUT FOR ISHANT ELECTRIC
ONE. ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA
RECENTLY RELEASED A REPORT
EXAMINING BUILDING
ELECTRIFICATION. AND CALIFORNIA
COULD STAND TO REAP SOME OF THE
HIGHEST BENEFITS IN THE COUNTRY
ELECTRIFY ALL OF OUR BUILDINGS
BY TWENTY FIFTY. WE CAN REDUCE
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA BY
TWENTY SEVEN POINT FOUR MILLION
METRIC TONS OF CARBON DIOXIDE.
AND THAT'S EQUAL TO TAKING
ABOUT SIX MILLION CARS OFF THE
ROAD. IN FACT CALIFORNIA RANKS
SECOND IN THE COUNTRY FOR THE
HIGHEST POTENTIAL GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS FROM
ELECTRIFYING BUILDINGS IN THE
NEXT THIRTY YEARS. THE REPORT
CONCLUDED THAT GOING ALL
ELECTRIC IN OUR STATE
BUILDINGS. WOULD HELP CUT
EMISSIONS IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND PROTECT THE PLANET. THIS
BILL ASKS CITIE AND COUNTIES
TO CREATE FEASIBLE
IMPLEMENTATION STRATEGIES. THAT
ENSURE THAT THEIR BUILDINGS
BECOME MORE SUSTAINABLE AND IS
A CRITICAL STEP FORWARD. I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB
THIRTY TWO AND I THINK YOU FOR
LETTING ME SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL TODAY THANKS THANKS SO
MUCH LIZZY NICKERSON
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY TWO
LAYS IN GERMAN WE ARE NOW GOING
TO CHECK IN TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. OF SB
THIRTY TWO HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. HEARING AND
SEEING NO ONE WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE GOING TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
LINE WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN WITH
OUR MODERATOR MR MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP. ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
TWO. NOW CERTAINLY SO LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW FOR US
FIRST IT LOOKS LIKE WE GOT A
LINE OF ONE NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ANTHONY
AND I'M A MEMBER OF SAN DIEGO
THREE FIFTY AND ONE OF THE
ORGANIZERS OF THIS SAN DIEGO
BUILDING ELECTRIFICATION
COALITION. A COALITION OF ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE- GROUPS WITHIN THE
SAN DIEGO REGION- I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT SB THIRTY TWO AND I
THANK CENTER CORTESE PERSONALLY
TO SHIP IN THE AREA OF
DECOMPENSATION. THANK YOU
THANKS AND SO MUCH AT RISK I
REMIND FOLKS IF YOU CAN PLEASE
GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND LAST
YEAR AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. MISTER
MODERATOR AT WE HAVE ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE IN Q. AT THE
MOMENT- YOU. LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. NEXTER SHOWING
ONLINE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LOOKING FOR A
MODEL WITH THE CLIMATE CENTRE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY THAT'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. LINE ONE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THAK YOU CAN DOLLARS DON'T
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION IN THE TO THE
ETHICS SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE PHONE CALL LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT WE
HAVE ONE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY THE DISTRICT AND
TRAIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SEARCHERS MISTER KHALKHAL A
HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT WE
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR CALLING IN TODAY LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE ONE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN BURKE PATHOLOGY OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA PARK THANK YOU THANKS
CRYSTAL. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY JAMES TO LAY UPS CHAIRPERSON
OF CARPENTRY SILICON VALLEY AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORTS SILICON
VALLEY- SB THIRTY SIX THANKS
THANK YOU SO MUCH JAMES NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BRING. ONE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS WAYNE TRONG I'M WITH
MOTHER SUBSTRUCTURE COMPELLING
IN OUR- OFFICE REBUILDING HOUSE
BY SILICON VALLEY- AND I
SUPPORT. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU CALLING IN TODAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. LINE ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KARAMANA BEGINNING SILICON
VALUE CLIMATE ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THE THIRTY TWO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING
IN LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
ONE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS SHERRY JOHNSON
REPRESENTING OUR TERRA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY TO
HAVE A GOOD WEEKEND YEAR THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS DR ROBERT
GOULD ON PRESIDENT BUT SAN
FRANCISCO BASED PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY. IT IS
NOT HAPPY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH DOCTOR
APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS ROD
STRINGS I AM IMMEDIATE PAST
CHAIR OF THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AND
FOUNDING CHAIR OF SILICON
VALLEY CLEAN ENERGY FALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WIND ONE
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. JERRY
DAY I AM A HIGH SCHOOL
SOPHOMORE AND ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY YOU ARE ACTION
AS WELL AS THE HARKER SCHOOL
GREEN TEAM WE STRONG CORE SB
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU APPRECIATE
YOU CALLING IN PLACE GENERALLY
ABOUT EIGHTEEN IN THE QUEUE
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
LINE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE SIXTY SEVEN YOU'RE
IN COMMITTEE I'M SORRY I MORE
INR WHETHER I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MOTHERS OUT FRONT
SILICON VALLEY YOUR GREAT
GRANDFATHER COULD CASES BILL
THANK YOU I THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANKS FOR CALLING IN. LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. WINE ONE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
I'M JENNY GREEN OF SAN JOSE
WITH MOTHERS OUT FRONT SILICON
VALLEY BANK THE COURT SB THIRTY
THANKS JENNY VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
RUBY STRICKLAND ON THE HALF OF
CALPERS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY TWO THANK YOUNG THANK
YOU SO MUCH RUBIO APPRECIATED
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS LINDA SELL AND I'M CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT FROM MY
ORGANIZATION BAY AREA FOR CLEAN
ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR COMMENT APPRECIATE
IT THANKS FOR HANGING WITH US
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE
NAY GALLAGHER FOR THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING
THAT'S GOOD OUR NEXT CALLER.
ONE ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS AT LEAST FONG
JACK WITH THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BATTLE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE IT. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE HELLO MY
NAME IS DON DRAPER WITH THE
SILICON VALLEY DEMOCRATIC CLUB
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF- BILL
THIRTY TWO. HE SHADED THANK YOU
FROM SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE
CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS JOE HEARD FROM
THE SAN DIEGO GREEN NEW DEAL
ALLIANCE CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY TWO G.
CONFERENCE SAN DIEGO TODAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WINE SIX NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
NICOLE KEMENY WITH THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY TWO
THANK YOU NICOLE BRIGITTE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE ZERO
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINED
UP. WITH THE HELLO YES THIS IS
JACK ONE AND WITH THE ACTED
DOWN CHEMICAL THE ACTON TOWN
COUNCIL CAN ONLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL TO THE EXTENT THAT IT DOES
NOT ELIMINATE NATURAL GAS AND
PROPANE IN AREAS THAT ARE
AFFECTED BY ROUTINE AND LIKE
THE P. S. P. S. ADVANTAGE
BECAUSE WE HAVE OUR ELECTRICITY
CUT FOR DAYS AT A TIME. AND IF
THIS GOES THROUGH AND WE YOU TO
CARBONIZED THE COMMUNITIES WE
WILL WILL FREEZE TO DEATH WE BE
UP THE CREEK SO IF YOU CAN
PLEASE SEE YOUR WAY TO MAKING
SURE THAT COMMUNITIES AFFECTED
BY PS PS ARE PICKING UP WILL
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH IS GONNA REMIND CALLERS WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
AND WE APPRECIATE YOU HANGING
WITH US. IF WE'RE JUST GOING TO
ASK YOU TO PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR
FIRST AND LAST NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION- WITH THE
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH AND AT
THE POSITION ON THE BILL AND
CURRENTLY WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE SB. THIRTY TWO NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. APRIL SHALL I BE OF
SIERRA CLUB LOMA PRIETA CHAPTER
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
REALLY APPRECIATED THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO WHEN ACR
AND THE HIGH SCHOOL JUNIOR AND
I'M WITH THE VALUE CLIMATE
ACTION AND I'M CALLING TRUMP OR
ABOUT YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR ADVOCACY WE
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
SUSAN WESTERN ON WITH THE
SIERRA CLUB LOWER CREATED
CHAPTER ENVIRONMENTAL
LEGISLATIVE ACTION COMMITTEE WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY TWO BECAUSE THE JUST
TRANSITION TO ZERO AM RIGHT
ENERGY EMISSIONS. IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL TO ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA REACHES THANK YOU H.
CURRENT CLIMATE ACTION GOALS
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU CALLING IN TODAY
THANKS FOR HANGING WITH US NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KATHY SHAFFER
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE
REALITY PROJECT IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
KATHY PRESHEAF OR PHONE CALL
TODAY NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS SHAYLA I'D I AM
CALLING ON BEHALF OF HIM AND
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS AND WE ARE
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
SHEILA NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE
ONE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MONICA NORMAN FROM SANTA
CLARA COUNTY REPRESENTING
SILICON VALLEY USE CORRECTION
CALLING FROM WORK THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE ONE TWELVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS ONION THE
BUT WITH MONDAY'S UPFRONT
MOBILIZING FOR A LIVABLE
CLIMATE FOR ALL CHILDREN
CALLING INTO WORK THANK YOU ON
YOUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE
HAVE NO FOR THE COLORS IN
SUPPORT MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR APPRECIATE THAT LAYS
IN GERMAN MONOGAMY GOING TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO SB
THIRTY TWO WE HAVE ONE AT LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS ON RIVER
TODAY THAT'S GOING TO BE SILVIO
FERRARI HE'S BACK WITH THIS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. MISTER
FERRARI AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
HANGING WITH US EARLIER AND
WORKING THROUGH THE TECHNICAL
CHALLENGES- BUT WE SHOULD BE
GOOD TO GO NOW SO WE'LL THE
FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES I'LL GIVE YOU A THIRTY
SECOND PROMPT IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THIRTY TWO. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
APPRECIATE BEING BACK WITH YOU-
CBI IS- INTO HOMES AND LET THE
MEN DID POSITION ON THE BILL
FIRST AND FOREMOST WANT TO
REALLY THANK AT THE OFFICE FOR
SPENDING TIME WITH US- TO TALK
THROUGH AND LISTEN TO OUR
CONCERNS REGARDING THE BILL-
CBI. IS NOT OPPOSED TO TYING
THE BILL THE DECARBONISATION
AND IN FACT. WE'VE BEEN WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS
BOTH AT A STAFF LEVEL AND THE
COMMISSION LEVEL- ON THIS VERY
ISSUE- I THINK- SEVERAL YEARS
AGO- THERE IS A LOT OF. ROCKETS
ABOUT THE FBI- BEING ABLE TO
GET TO A POINT IN TIME WHERE WE
COULD SUPPORT A SOLAR MANDATE
ON ONLY RESIDENTIAL HOUSING
THAT MNDATE IS NOW IN EFFECT
AS OF TWENTY TWENTY. AND THAT
WAS SPECIFICALLY I THINK
REPRESENTATIVE OF ARC VIEW OF
WORKING TOWARD EFFORTS TO
DECARBONISE RESIDENTIAL
HOUSING- WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORED
APPRECIATED COMMENTS EARLIER-
MOVING FORWARD TO JUST MAKE
SURE THE BILL IS LASER FOCUSED.
WHEN IT COMES TO BE PART OF IT
IN REGARDS TO ENERGY USE OF
RESIDENTIAL HOMES SO- WE ARE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED BUT THANK
THE AUTHOR AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HIM MOVING
FORWARD. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH THAT SILVIO FERRARI FROM
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION ARE ONE
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS NOW
LAYS IN GERMAN BURKE AND
CHECKING TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. CURRENCY KNOWN RUSH
FORWARD WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
GOING TO OUR PHONE LINES ARE
GONNA CHECK IN WITH OUR
MODERATOR MR MODERATOR. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE WHO IS IN OPPOSITION.
OF SB THIRTY TWO NOW. THANK YOU
THOSE IN OFFICE TO ASK THIRTY
TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOW BY
C. NOW. US FIRST WITH TO LINE
ONE ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HE JACQUELYN THERE I
APOLOGIZE FOR SPEAKING EARLIER
INCORRECTLY. AFTER TOWN COUNCIL
OPPOSES THIS LESS AMENDED TO
ADDRESS P. S. B. ISSUES THANK
YOU GOT IT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
WE APPRECIATE THAT THAT'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT WE HAVE
ONE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FORTY NINE URINE COMMITTEE.
THAT'S TO. W. W. WAS NOT AWARE
ABOUT ANYWAYS- THE HEROES WE
BELIEVE YOU COVER RELATIONS
PRESS ALL THROUGH THE REGULAR
PROCESS THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH APPRECIATE YOU CALLING IN
TODAY LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE NO FOR
THE COLORS IN OPPOSITION TO
STRICTER ALL RIGHT MISS
MODERATOR NICE WORK SIR WE'RE
GOING TO TURN IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF WE HAVE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR MOTION
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR EMOTION.
PLEASE ENTER DRAWS A. VERY VERY
IMPORTANT PERSONAL QUESTION FOR
ME HOW MY GONNA WAR MIGHT
THIRTY OF ANOTHER TEXT OF. JUST
KIDDING THERE YOU GO IT'S A
IT'S A GOOD QUESTION ACTUALLY-
YEAH. THAT'S RIGHT A GUY. I
LOVE IT- EIGHTY QUESTIONS OR
COME ALL RIGHT HEARING C.
NINETY THERE A MOTION WE A
MOTION BY SENATOR I DON'T
SENATOR TO WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSELY. THANK YOU AND I'M JUST
OF I'VE DONE A ON AN ELECTRIC
COOPS DON'T TO BE LEAVES THE
MARKS ON THE THIRTIETH. I THANK
ALL. HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
BUILDING CODES IT TO SIMPLY
SAYS WHATEVER THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE DOING OR INTENT TO
DO- PLANTED TO WHETHER THAT'S A
LOT OR A LITTLE WE SHOULD SHOW
THAT IN THE GENERAL PLAN
DOCUMENTS SO THAT THE REST OF
US CAN SEE WHAT THEY'RE DOING
FUNDAMENTALLY THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
CORTESE LAYS IN GENERAL
COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER DRAWS-
MISTER NOW CAN YOU PLEASE
PROVIDE THE PROPER MOTION AND-
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE- A
SENATOR NIELSEN. HE'LL NO.
SENATE DORADO. DORADO I SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER. TWO
ONE ALL RIGHT THAT'S CURRENTLY
TO ONE BUT WE GOT A HORSE RACE
GOING LAYS IN GERMAN SO HERE'S
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN- AND
WE'RE GOING TO ADD ON SENATOR
WIENER IN THE MAJORITY LEADER
WHEN THEY GET BACK TO COMMITTEE
SECRETASE YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERY
GRATEFUL- IN APPRECIATE YOUR
ADVOCACY- ITS INTERPRETATION AS
WELL ALL RIGHT MAYES GERMAN WE
HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS WE GOT
TENER OTRO ABOVIAN COMMITTEE
RIGHT NOW- MADAM SENATOR I DO
WANNA LET YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AT SO WHAT
THAT MEANS IS THAT WE'RE GONNA
ASK YOU TO GIVE A TRUNCATED
VERSION OF YOUR STATEMENT I
SENT YOU A BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
SO THE FLOOR IS YOURS. WELCOME
TO COMMITTEE IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU THANK YOU THINK HERE I AM.
OKAY SO RELATED RENOWNED SUPER
SUPER EXCITED ASK FOR THE
SUPPORT. AS YOU KNOW- RIGHT NOW
OUT THE CALIFORNIA EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT PROGRAM WAS
CREATED TO FIGHT POVERTY AMONG
WORKING FAMILIES ESPECIALLY
THOSE WITH YOUNG CHILDREN AND
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
HELPING A LOT OF THESE-
FAMILIES WHO HAVE REALLY BEEN
AFFECTED BY. BY THE PANDEMIC IN
ORDER TO GET MORE BUT I THINK
WOULDN'T JUST WENT FOR IT. IS
FREE ON THAT- REALLY AB RIGHT.
NOT PART OF MY PRESENTATION
BAKER FRANK. GOD MY FACT SHEET.
PLEASE FOLLOW- INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVE A TAX REFUND FROM THE
CREDIT TYPICALLY SPEND THEIR
REFUND AN ESSENTIAL NEEDS IN
FACT 70% OF RECIPIENTS SPENT A
PORTION OF THEIR REFUND AND
HOUSING AND FOOD PROFIT 46% OF
INDIVIDUAL SPENT A PORTION OF
THAT WE FOUND ON SCHOOL
SUPPLIES. CLOTHING AND SHOES.
ON BEHALF OF THE MANY FAMILIES
THAT THIS WILL BE HELPING YOU
THINK THE PERSON BEFORE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THE TWENTY MOM TO SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO THE GOOD
SENATOR FOR ALL HAVE HER WORK
ON IT SO IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE
TO WORK WITH YOU AND YOUR TEAM-
IN THIS IS SUCH A CRITICAL
ISSUE SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAM SENATOR OUT FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. DELAYS IN GENERAL
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO OUR
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS. WE HAVE
DYNEIN MICHELETTI COLBERN- WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAM ASSOCIATION-
SHE IS GOING TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY AS OUR LEAD SUPPORT
WHEN IT'S AN S. B. TWO SEVENTY
SIX. MISS NICOLINI COBURN. YOU
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
COMMITTEE YOU DO HAVE UP TO
THREE MINUTES BUT SINCE YOU
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I THINK
WE'RE NEVER PRETTY GOOD OUTCOME
HERE IN COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS MA'AM. I'LL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT WE WELCOME.
YOU TO GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
PLEASE PROCEED. BERMAN
ACQUIRING. THANK YOU MUCH
NICKELBERRY. THE CALL.
ALTERNATIVE CAME ACROSS. THAT
ARE PROGRAMS THAT MINISTER. BY
CHILD CARE. YOUR PROGRAMS FOR
OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILDREN. ARE COMMUNITY BASED
PUBLIC AND NONPROFIT AGENCIES
PROVIDING SUPPORT FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES THE CHILD CARE-
PROGRAM. MENTAL HEALTH THAT
AWFUL WITH OTHERS FOR. FAILING
WE ARE SEEN IN HELPING FAMILIES
RAVAGED BY THE FACT THAT THIS
PANDEMIC. DURING THE PANDEMIC
WE'VE EXPANDED OUR SUPPORT TO
AUTHENTICALLY IT MEDIAN CHILD
CARE NEEDS OFESSENTIAL
WORKERS. FROM OUR FIRSTHAND
VANTAGE POINT WE KNOW THAT
REDUCING THE TAX BURDEN
FOLLOWED IT IN. A MODERATE
INCOME EARNERS. WILL DIRECTLY
SUPPORT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIA FAMILY.
ADDITIONALLY I WANT TO NOTE
THAT THIS CREDIT HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO ALSO PROVIDE. SOME
RELIEF TO THE TENS OF THOUSANDS
THE FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. AND THE CHILD CARE
WORKFORCE WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO
KEEP AFLOAT. KEEP THEIR DOORS
OPEN. THE MOST FRAGILE FAMILIES
AND WORKERS. I'M FROM OUR LAND.
OVERWHELMINGLY IT'S MAINLY
BLACK AND BROWN FAMILY HEADED
UP BY A SINGLE MOM. WHO HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BEEN
IMPACTED BY FOR A LOS LAYOFFS
AND DISTANCE LEARNING DUE TO
SCHOOL CLOSURES. ARE THE ONES
THAT WILL FILL THE RELIEF THAT
THE TWO SEVEN SIX. BY ALLOWING
TAXPAYERS THE FLEXIBILITY TO
CHOOSE THE INCOME YEAR THAT
WILL PROVIDE. THEM THE GREAT
FRIENDLY. YEAH PLEASED WITH THE
EVERY DAY. THIS RELIEF
IMMEDIATE BE TO USE BY PAYING
LATE THEY'LL AND CUT FOOD ON
THE TABLE. THANK YOU SENATE
TELL FROM CAP HELP YOUR- AND
MAKING FOR THE FIVE. SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HIM FOR-
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY REALLY FOR
WORK IT'S WELL AS IN GENERAL
COMMITTEE WHERE GOING TO CHECK.
TO SEE IF THERE IS ANY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVEN SIX
YEAR ROOM THIRTY NINETY ONE.
CURRENCY KNOWN COME FORWARD
WERE NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELEPHONE LINE WE'RE GONNA
CHECK IN WITH MR MODERATOR MR
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVENTY SIX.
NOW CERTAINLY THANK YOU THOSE
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO NOW FOR US. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO COLOR SCHEMES
BY PHONE. ALL RIGHT AT THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER MODERATOR WE
ARE NOW GOING TO. TURN IT OVER
TO THOSE WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL WE'RE
GOING TO FIRST START HERE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE TO
BE A TO SEE IF THERE IS ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD NOW.
HEARING SEE NO ONE MISTER
MODERATOR WE ARE BACK AT YOU
WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN TO SEE IF
THERE IS ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. TWO SEVENTY SIX. THANK
YOU AND I WAS IN OPPOSITION TO
IN TO SB TWO SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW
FOR US. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
ONE QUEUING IN OPPOSITION
MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT AT
LAZING GENTLEMAN WE'RE GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO SEE IF THERE ARE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS EVER
GOING TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. FROM
COMMITTEE CAN YOU GIVE US-
SIXTY SECOND PLACE IN TERMS
SIXTY SECONDS PLEASE. ALL RIGHT
IS THERE PLEASE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION BY THE
VICE CHAIR WITH A MOTION BY THE
FIGHT VICE CHAIR ON THE FLOOR
YOU NEED TO TIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS HERE AND SEEN ON
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
WORK ON THIS WE ARE SO
GRATEFUL- PLEASE FOR YOUR
CLOTHES. I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU OUR HEARTFELT THANK
YOU TO ALL THAT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. AND I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
ALL RIGHTS INNER CHOI BOGUE
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL URINE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FOCUS. WE ARE GOING TO HEAR THE
MOTION IN CALL THE ROLL MISTER
NOW. THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE. HI MCGUIRE HIS
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN FIVE
SENATOR DORADO. DORADO FIVE
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER. THREE ZERO THREE ZERO
BUT WE GOT SOME BI PARTISANSHIP
GOING ON HERE AND COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF TOLD VOGUE
VERY VERY GRAVE OF A WONDERFUL
WEEKEND THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH US AS WELL. ALL RIGHT SO
HI LADIES AND GENTLEMAN WE HAVE
THREE BILLS LEFT THREE BILLS
LEFT. NOW THE VICE CHAIR KNOWS
THIS WE HAVE A- A TRADITION
MISTER VICE CHAIR- YEAH I'LL-
FORMER SIR MORLOCK. USED TO DO
EVEN IF YOU REMEMBER LAST YEAR
HE SANG A LITTLE BIT- WHEN WE
DIDN'T HAVE AN OFFER I WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CARRY ON THAT
TRADITION- MISTER VICE YEAR. I
A LITTLE THING IN IN BETWEEN
NOT HAVING ANOTHER. I THAT WAS
A HELL NOVEMBER. IN DRAWS
ALREADY LEAVING SOCHI THANK BY
ALL RIGHT LOSING DON'T GIVE US
JUST A BIT STICKY FIVE MINUTE
FIVE MINUTE RECESS WE'LL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU WE ARE ON
THE HUNT FOR SENATOR SKINNER.
SENATOR JONES AND SENATOR
BRADFORD AT SID FROM THE
SERGEANT'S OFFICE IS DIALING A
RIGHT NOW SO SENATOR SKINNER
CENTER JONES IN CENTER BRADFORD
IS A NEEDED IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINE ONE FIVE MINUTES WILL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU. YEAH
RIGHT. OKAY. RIGHT OKAY THE
SLOW BOTH YOUR HEART WHERE DO I
GO THERE. I GO THERE. NO I
YOU'RE RIGHT ON TIME RIGHT
SORRY I'M NOT USED TO THE
LITTLE BOTH. ALL RIGHT LAYS IN
GERMAN WE ARE BACK WITH YOU- WE
SAID FIVE MINUTES- AND LOOK AT
THIS CENTER SKINNER IS GONE
FROM COMMITTEE TO COMMITTEE
RIGHT NOW IT'S COMING IN HERE
TO ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE.
ALL RIGHT SENATE SCANNERS AND
WORKING ON SB TWO NINETY
FOCUSING ON DENSITY BONUS IN
THIS IS BEEN AN ISSUE FOR HER-
AND SHE'S A HOUSING CHAMPION
HERE IN THE SENATE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS- MADAM SENATOR ON SB TWO
NINETY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AS- THE
CHAIR INDICATED THIS IS A
REINTRODUCTION. OF A BILL THAT
WAS- VERY SUCCESSFUL LAST YEAR
IN FACT GOT THE FLOOR VOTE FROM
THE ASSEMBLY OF SIXTY SEVEN
VOTES AND IT OF COURSE HAD GONE
TO OUR HOUSE- IT WAS COMING
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE WHEN WE
HAD THAT LOVELY LAST DAY OF
SESSION. WE'RE MANY BILLS DID
NOT GET BACK TO US IN TIME FOR
A MIDNIGHT DEADLINE SO I'M
REINTRODUCING THIS BECAUSE IT
IS VERY IMPORTANT. TO
CALIFORNIA'S DENSITY BONUS LAW
THAT WILL HELP US ENSURE THAT
THE DENSITY BONUS LAW IS
WORKING AND HOPEFULLY MORE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS USE IT.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE LESS
THAN HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT HAVE APPROVED
PROJECTS USING THE DENSITY
BONUS SPECIFICALLY THE BILL.
ALLOWS THE DENSITY BONUS TO
USED STUDENT HOUSING. IT
CONFORMS DENSITY BONUS APPROVAL
WITH REQUIREMENTS AND HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. EXPANDS THE
DEFINITION OF FOR SALE PROJECTS
BEYOND CMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS INCLUDING UNITS
FOR LOWINCOME FAMILIES. AND
ADDS A PARKING WAIVER FOR SALE
PROJECTS. THAT ARE WITHIN A
HALF MILE OF TRANSIT IN INCLUDE
FORTY PERCENT. OF MODERATE
INCOME UNITS AND WHILE LET MY
WITNESSES NOW SPEAK AND I'VE
DAVID GARCIA FROM UC BERKELEY'S
TURNER CENTER. AND PATRICK
KENNEDY FROM PANORAMIC INTEREST
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER SKINNER THERE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO OUR PHONE LINES
TO BE TO TALK TO OUR TO. LEAD
WITNESSES LET'S START WITH MR
GARCIA FROM THE TURNER CENTER
AT UC BERKELEY MR GARCIA YOU
ARE NOW IN COMMITTEE YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES I'LL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT PLEASE
PROCEED SIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DAVID
GARCIA I IN THE POLICY DIRECTOR
A TEACHER CENTER HOUSING
INNOVATION. AT UC BERKELEY IT
WE ARE A HOUSING RESEARCH AND
POLICY ORGANIZATION. AT THE
UNIVERSITY FOCUSING ON ALL
MATTERS OF HOUSING RELATED
ISSUES FROM LAND USE- YOU THE
COST OF BUILDING HOUSING. FOR
MANY YEARS SIMPLY HOMES TO
MULTI FAMILY CONSTRUCTION. I
THINK TODAY I'M HERE TO TESTIFY
THAT SPECIFICALLY SUPPORT THE
SENATE BILL TWO NINETY FROM
SENATOR SKINNER IN PRINCIPLE
BECAUSE OUR WORK HAS SHOWN THAT
THE DENSITY BONUS LAW. SHOULD
BE REFORMED TO ENCOURAGE
GREATER USE THAT SPECIFICALLY
ARE TWENTY NINETEEN CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTIAL LAND USE SURVEY.
FOUND THAT FROM TWENTY FIFTEEN
THROUGH TWENTY SEVENTEEN MORE
THAN HALF OF JURISDICTION
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA REPORTED
TO US. THAT THEY HAD NO WILL
GET. THE BONUS USAGE WHATSOEVER.
AND THE CITY THE COUNTY. THAT'S
A LOOK AT THE HAVE IT HE WAS
PROBABLY MOST OF THE DISHES
REPORT HAVING. JUST ONE OR TWO
HE PUT US CRIED. DURING THAT
SAME. SO THIS IS THIS COULD US
THAT CHANGES THEN PEOPLE
FLORIDA NEED. TO INCREASE ITS
USAGE SHOULD GOT TO DRIVE JUST
HOUSE CONSTRUCTION A WORLD ALSO.
YOUR SHIFTED AFFORDABLE THAT
COULD. WHEN USING THE TERM HE-
WE BELIEVE THAT HURDLE TO
NINETY TAKE IMPORT. TARGETED
STEP TO IMPROVING YOUR- OF THIS
LAW. LIKE SPENDING. THE COULD
ONLY HOMEOWNERS. IF YOU HAVE A
PROVISION BOTH OUR CREDIT AREAS
OF NEED HEARING. IT IS ARE
SIMPLE. ORDER FORMS THAT COULD
HELP YOU MORE ABOUT. TOWARD
USING A YUBA IN MORE. ACROSS
THE STATE. AT THE END JULY
WHICH OF THE- ACCORDING TO. AND
THAT. I WANT TO THANK. THEM
SKINNER FOR SENIOR WORK ON THIS
ISSUE- EMPLOYED OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. TODAY-
UNLIMITED THAT- CAN I HAVE A
THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH FOR
CIGARETTES HERE FROM UC
BERKELEY'S TURNER CENTER WERE
NOW GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO
PATRICK KENNEDY FROM. PANORAMIC
INTEREST MISTER KENNEDY YOU ARE
NOW IN COMMITTEE YOUR THREE
MINUTES I'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY
SECOND. PROMPT THE FLOOR IS
YOURS PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES YOU COMING IN AND
CLEAR THE FLOOR OF LOS. OKAY
GRANT GRANT- MY NAME IS CAN ON
THE- OF PANORAMIC INTERESTS-
BASED IN SANTA. NOW I STARTED
WORKING IN BERKELEY THIRTY
YEARS AGO AND IN FACT- WAS THE
FIRST DEVELOPER TO USE THE
DENSITY BONUS. IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE IN BERKELEY.
BETWEEN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE IN
TWO THOUSAND FIVE I TALK ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED APARTMENTS IN
BERKELEY. THAT INCLUDED THE USE
THAT UTILIZED THE DENSITY
BONUS. AND RESULTED IN THE
CREATION OF NINETY UP TO
APPROXIMATELY NINETY. BELOW
MARKET RATE UNITS- IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. I USE THE DENSITY
BONUS AGAIN IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I'VE USED IT ON TWO
SUBSEQUENT PROJECTS PRODUCING
THIRTY SIX. VERY LOW INCOME
UNITS IN TOTAL IN THE SPACE OF
ABOUT. FIFTEEN YEARS FIFTEEN
PLUS YEARS- THE DENSITY BONUS
RESULTED IN THE CREATION OF
CLOSE TO. THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX. WELL INCOME APARTMENTS AT
NO COST TO THE CITIES WHERE
THEY RAN. AND WITH CREE
MANAGEMENT BY THE MARKET RATE
DEVELOPER BUT THE MARKET RATE
MANAGEMENT FIRMS THAT WE- THAT
WE HAVE EMPLOYED IN SHORT- THE
DENSITY BONUSES BEEN EXTREMELY
ATTRACTIVE AND VALUABLE. TOOL
FOR US AND FOR OTHER
DEVELOPERS. TO CREATE- BELOW
MARKET RATE- UNITS AT NO COST
TO THE CITY AND WITHOUT TAKING
THE UNITS OFF THE TAX ROLLS
IT'S- BUT IT'S BEEN A MORE-
MARVELOUS SUCCESS. IN BOTH SAN
FRANCISCO AND BERKLEY. AND AND
SENATORS SCANNERS EFFORTS TO
EXPAND IT. TO STUDENT HOUSING.
TO MODERATE INCOME HOUSING AND
TO OTHER KINDS OF HOUSING- IS-
ABOUT VALUABLE AND I THINK.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT EXPANSION
OF THE DENSITY BONUS- IT.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THE
DENSITY BONE- WORTH NOTING IS
THAT MAKE IT EASY. FOR LOCAL.
TO SUPPORT PROJECTS BECAUSE IN
EFFECT THEY HAVE- THEY HAVE NO
LATITUDE TO DENY THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE NO LATITUDE
THE DIET AND IT AND WHEN IT'S
STATE LAW IT'S MUCH EASIER. FOR
ALL PARTIES INVOLVED TO SIMPLY
SAY THERE'S NOTHING WE CAN DO
TO IMPROVE THE TO STOP THIS
PROJECT STATE LAW BECAUSE
PROVIDING. VALUABLE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THIRTY SEVEN- SO I'D
LIKE TO ENCOURAGE YOU. OF THAT
THREE OKAY THEN I LIKE THE
COURAGE A PASSENGER SCANNERS.
MARKET WHAT. ENHANCE ALL.
PROVEN AND BY- TOOLS SAYS NEED
A IN THE SAID IN A AND THEN
STATE THANK YOU I YOU SO MUCH
MISTER KENNEDY WE REALLY PREACH
YOU CALLING IN TODAY SPEND SO
MUCH TIME WITH US WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU SIR. BASINGER AND
WE'RE NOT GONNA CHECKING TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM THIRTY ONE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. OF SB TWO NINETY
HEARING CENA AND NO ONE WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR
PHONE LINES ARE GONNA CHECK IN
WITH MR MODERATOR MR RIGHT
MODERATOR GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN.
LET'S CUE UP ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
OF SB TWO NINETY EIGHT NOW.
CERTAINLY THANK YOU THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO NINETY PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW.
FIRST WE HAVE LIKE ONE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. LAUREN
TABLE AND GET REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MORE AND THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. ONE ONE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DISNEY FAN ON
BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING AT THE
PARK REALLY APPRECIATE THANK
YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. LINE ONE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THE FEDERAL
DOLLARS BOND WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT A PEDRO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL AS ALWAYS THAT'S A
CHECK IN FOR WITH OUR NEXT
CALLER. WINE ONE FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
PHILADELPHIA CLAIMS ON BEHALF
OF SILICON VALLEY AND AT HOME
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MANY DEALS
REPRESENTING THE FAN OF THE
EVERGREEN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
THANKS SO MUCH MR DS NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. KEVIN
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
PHONE CALL THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT CALLER. ONE FIVE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS OF
ERIN EVANS CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY OF
CALIFORNIA BURKE CALIFORNIA
MEET TMG PARTNERS AS WELL AS
THE GREENBELT ALLIANCE ALL OF
THE PARK THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR SEVENS. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WINE ONE FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE FIFTY
THREE YEAR IN COMMITTEE. LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER MISTER
MODERATE. WINE ONE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FORTY SIX
DURING COMMITTEE. NEXT CALLER
MISTER MODERN. NEXT WE HAVE ONE
ONE FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALL RIGHT- COLOR YOU ARE IN
COMMITTEE. WE GOT SOME HEAVY
BREATHING GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
NINE ONE FIVE TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS JOSH AGGRESSION
WITH SOUTH PASADENA RESIDENTS
FOR RESPONSIBLE GROWTH IN THE
COURT IF YOU'RE MUCH THANK YOU
SO MUCH APPRECIATE THE PHONE
CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
WE HAVE ONE LINE ONE FIVE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE ADAM WRIGHTWOOD
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO NINETY
THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE NO
FOR THE COLORS IN SUPPORT
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH WAS THE MODERATOR
WERE NOT TO BE GOING TO
OPPOSITION WE'RE GONNA SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL. SB TWO NINETY HERE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
HEARING IN SEEN ON COME FOREVER
NOT GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
MODERATOR. MISTER MODERATOR
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME SINCE WE
TALKED YES SO WOULD LIKE TO
OPPOSITION. TO SB TWO NINETY
CAN YOU PLEASE. QUEUE UP ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO NINETY
NOW. CERTAINLY IDEA ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO NINETY
ONCE AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. FIRST WE ARE ALIGNED ONE
FOUR SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE ONE FOUR SIX YOU'RE IN
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE ONE FIVE FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I GET AFTERNOON I
ACTUALLY MEANT TO BE IN INDIA
SUPPORT QUEUE- AND IF IT'S LOSE
MONEY YOU'LL GENERATION HOUSING
CALLING IN SUPPORT- OF- AT THE
TWO NINETY THANK YOU HE SAYS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING
GOOD TO HEAR FROM YOU SIR LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. LINE ONE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
FIFTY YOU ARE CURRENTLY IN
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE NO FOR
THE COLORS IN OPPOSITION MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA TURN IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR MOTION QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR EMOTION. ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE WE
HAVE A MOTION BY APPROVED BY
THE VICE CHAIR VICE CHAIR
NIELSEN THANK YOU SO MUCH- IN
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS HERE AND SEE NONE
THAT'S GOING TO CENTER SKINNER
FOR THE CLOSE. THANK YOU AYE
OSCAR AYE VOTE ALL RIGHT DID WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR MR
NOW CAN YOU PLEASE PROVIDE THE
FORMAL MOTION IN CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HIS SENATOR
DORADO. DORADO HIS SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER THREE
ZERO ALL RIGHT THREE ZERO-
MEDICINE- WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT
BILL ON HOLD AND ON CALL IN
WILL I GET MR MAJORITY LEADER
IS WELL SIR WIENER ON THERE.
ACP THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL
RIGHT I THINK WE'RE ACTUALLY
THINKING ABOUT TWO AM NOW
BECAUSE- THAT HOUSING COMMITTEE
IS. ITS ONGOING IT'S A IT'S A
GOOD TIMES. SANDRA THOSE S.
ALSO BE ON HOUSING NOW SO- IF.
LEADING ALL RIGHT WE'RE BRING
IT UP THAT'S- GO WE'RE WE'RE
BRINGING UP A SINNER JONES MR
JONES WELCOME MISTER JONES- WE
GOT SOME GOOD NEWS WE HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SIR. SO WITH
THAT BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WE ARE
GOING TO ASK FOR A TRUNCATED
VERSION OF YOUR STATEMENT THAT
WE WELCOME USER INTO. MR JONES
HAS BEEN WORKING ON THIS ISSUE
WE REALLY APPRECIATE ALL OF
YOUR HARD WORK SIR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS ON SB FOUR ONE FOUR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'LL TAKE THAT
AS MY OPEN AND MY CLOTHES AND
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT
YOU WANT TO JUST GIVE US A
QUICK GUIDE TWENTY SECOND ON
THE SECOND ON YOUR REQUEST YES
WE ARE SENATE BILL FOUR
FOURTEEN UPDATE SEVERAL
PROVISIONS OF CODE GOVERNING
LAND SURVEYORS. FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THIS COMMITTEE SB
FOUR FOURTEEN EXTENDS THE
DEADLINE FOR CONDUCTING APPEALS
OF LOCAL DECISIONS ON TENTATIVE
MAPS FROM THIRTY TO FORTY FIVE
DAYS. WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS A LETTER AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED THAT ITEM SHOULD
HAVE BEEN TAKEN UP IN B. AND P.
R. WILL WORK ON IT WE'LL GET IT
FIXED AND- MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
CORRECT- BEFORE IT GOES OVER TO
THE ASSEMBLY SO ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE YEAH ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A JONES AND THAT
WHAT. YEAH HE'S REFERRING TO
ITS IT WITHIN THE BEING P.
JURISDICTION NOT NECESSARILY IN
THE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
JURISDICTION- AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I MISTER JONES
WILL BE TACKLING HERE IN THE
COMING WEEKS AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR SURGEONS FOR THE
INFORMATION THAT AS WELL. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE ONE LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESS THAT'S MISTER BELOW MR
BLOW REPRESENTS THE CALIFORNIA
LAND SURVEYORS ASSOCIATION MR
BELOW DO YOU CURRENTLY HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SUPPORT ON
THE BILL WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR
A TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR
STATEMENT. THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR YOU OF UP TO THREE MINUTES
AND I'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND.
PROMPT WELCOME TO COMMITTEE
MIKE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. BELOW ON BEHALF
THE CO. LANCE ASSOCIATE I WOULD
THANK THE CONSULTANT A REALLY
FINE ANALYSIS IF SOMEBODY
WANTED A FOUR PARAGRAPH SUMMARY
OF HOW THE PLANNING AND ZONING
LAW WORKS. AND HOW IT RELATES
TO THE SUBDIVISION MAP ACT THEY
COULDN'T DO BETTER THAN THIS-
CITIES AND COUNTIES- SURVEYOR'S
REPORT THAT THEY HAVE TROUBLE
GETTING THESE- CALENDAR IT
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS WHICH SETS
FORTH ALL SORTS OF HOOPS THAT
THAT. PUBLIC HAVE TO GO
THROUGH- THIS SIMPLY GIVES THEM
TWO MORE WEEKS TO CONDUCT THESE
APPEALS AND WE WOULD ASK FOR AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER BLOAT AND WE WANT TO
GIVE CREDIT WHERE CREDIT IS
DUE- ANTENNA ANTON SEVERINI
CHARBAGH WHO WAS THE CONSULTANT
ON THIS FROM GOVERNS FINANCE
DOES AN AMAZING JOB AS IS THE
ENTIRE. GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
TEAM SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER BLOAT FOR DOING THE SHOT
OUT TO AN TIME VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT E'RE GONNA NOW I LOOK TO
HEAR IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE TO SEE IF THERE IS ANY
INDIVIDUAL WOULD LIKE TO GO TO
COME FORWARD AND SPEAK TO US.
IN SUPPORT OF FOUR ONE FOUR
HEARING SEEING NO ONE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BRING IT TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE ON. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE'RE GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO MR MODERATOR MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF FOUR
ONE FOUR. SB. FOUR ONE FOUR IN
SUPPORT NOW. CERTAINLY DOESN'T.
OF SB FOUR ONE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO IMMEDIATELY. AS THE
MODERATOR IS GIVING FOLKS UP WE
WANT TO REMIND FOLKS THAT YOU
CAN NOW COMMUNICATE WITH THE
COMMITTEE TOLL FREE TODAY ON
ANY BILL THAT PHONE NUMBER IS.
877-336-4436 MISTER MODERATOR.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE
COMING UP IN SUPPORT MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR WE ARE GONNA BE BACK
WITH YOU MOMENTARILY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO OPPOSITION WE'D
LIKE TO GO TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR
ONE FOUR. HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. HEARING SEEN NO
ONE IN OPPOSITION LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO
TALK TO YOU GUESSED IT MISTER
MODERATOR HE IS BACK AND READY
TO GO WE'RE LOOKING FOR THOSE
WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION. OF SB
FOUR ONE FOUR CAN YOU PLEASE Q.
THOSE FOLKS UP NOW MR MODERATOR.
CERTAINLY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO IMMEDIATELY.
FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOUR ONE FOUR ONCE AGAIN ONE
FOLLOWED BY. ZERO AND AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE COMING UP
IN OPPOSITION MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT THIS IS A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT BUILDINGS IN GERMAN
WITH ACTIVITY SEE IF WE HAVE A
MOTION WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER VICE CHAIR MISTER VICE
YEAR ANY ITEMS THAT YOU'D LIKE
TO GO TO COMMENT ON THIS. HERE
AND SEE NINE ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH SO NO COMMENTS HERE
FROM THE COMMITTEE WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY VICE
CHAIR NIELSEN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR VICE CHAIR. SENATOR WOULD
YOULIKE TO CLOSE I THINK
YOU'VE DONE A GREAT JOB GERMAN
ALLIES FROM A VOTE ALL RIGHT WE
GOT TO. BE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR MISTER NOW CAN YOU PLEASE
PROVIDE THE MOTION IN CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE AYE
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN AYE
AYES SENATOR DORADO DORADO. HIS
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SO WIENER.
THREE ZERO THREE THREE ZERO-
THAT BILL IS ON HOLD WE'RE
GONNA KEEP IT OPEN UNTIL WE
HAVE CENTER WIENER MAJORITY
LEADER BACK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH ALL RIGHT SO HERE'S WHERE
WE STAND LAYS IN GERMAN- WE
HAVE. A SERGEANT WHO IS OUT
TRACKING DOWN SENATOR BRADFORD
CENTER BRADFORD IS THE FINAL
BILL THAT IS IN FRONT OF US
HERE THIS WEEK NOW. THERE HE IS
THE MAN THE MYTH FROM LOS
ANGELES A LEGEND AND THAT'S AT
SENATORS STEVE- JUST WANT TO
REMIND FOLKS QUICK HOUSEKEEPING
FOR NEXT WEEK- TRULY BRING YOUR
CAMPING GEAR IT IS GOING TO BE
A LONG HEARING NEXT WEEK. SO WE
GOT ALONG ONE COMING UP AND
THEN WE WON'T MEET UNTIL MAY
FIFTH AFTER NEXT WEEK. SO WILL
MEET ON THE TWENTY SECOND WE'RE
BACK AT IT ON THE FIFTH OF MAY.
SO LAYS IN GENERAL NOW MOVING
TO ITEM NUMBER NINE OR FINAL
ITEM FOR TODAY THIS IS SB SIX
OH THREE AT CENTER BRAD FURMAN
GIVE YOU SOME GOOD NEWS WE GOT
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THE BILL.
SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR A
TRUNCATED VERSION YOUR
STATEMENT THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AND JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE THE FORRESTER
RESEARCH ASK FOR A VOTE HEY
THERE YEAH. IF YOU WANT TO GIVE
THE THIRTY SECOND OVERVIEW OF
THE YEAH REAL QUICK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS- THIS IS
CANDACE BE WHEREVER DEFERRALS-
HELPING A LOCAL- APPLICANTS IN
A- INEQUITY PROGRAM. IT EXTENDS
WHAT WE DID- TWO YEARS AGO SB
FIVE NINE FIVE IT PROVIDED A
FEE WAIVER DEFERRAL PROGRAM
FOR. THOSE INDIVIDUALS. LOOKING
TO ENTER THE SPACE SPECIALLY
WOMEN ALL MINORITY ON A
DISABLED VETERAN OWNED.
BUSINESSES WHO FONG CHALLENGES-
ENTERING THE SPACE DUE TO THE-
HIGH COST OF THE INJURY AND THE
FEES AND ALL THAT SO THIS. NOW
PROVIDES EITHER. DEFERRAL OR
TAX CREDIT FOR THOSE FOR WHO
LOW TO. CANNABIS SPACE I RISK
ASK FOR VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IN YOUR B. S. MISTER. BUT I SAY
NO ONE IN THIS. HAS BEEN FOR.
ON ISSUE OF EQUITY MORE THAN
YOU HAVE WHEN IT COMES TO ALL
ISSUES OF CANNABIS BUSINESS- IN
IT'S BEEN AN ISSUE THAT YOU
HAVE BEEN FOCUSING ON FOR MANY
YEARS AND WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR WORK- IN FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS BILL. AT THE
CENTER YOU'RE GONNA TAKE THE
TECHNICAL MEANS UNDER SAM ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU
CAN BE TAKEN TECHNICAL MEANS SO
WE HAVE ONE LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESS WHO'S WITH US. THAT'S
ERIC HOLMSTROM- FROM THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COALITION
MISTER WHOLESOME WE WELCOME YOU
TO COMMITTEE YOU DO HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT RIGHT NOW.
AT SO THE FLOOR IS YOURS ARE
YOU OF UP TO THREE MINUTES. AND
I'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR AND
SENATORS MY NAME'S OUR CULTURE
BONDED TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COALITION. FIRST I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR BRADFORD FOR
OFFERING THIS MEASURE AND
OTHERS TO HELP LOCAL SOCIAL.
EQUITY PROGRAMS OF RESOURCES
FROM THE STATE TO HELP
INTERESTED STAFF. AT THE BILL
STARTED OVER FIVE YEARS AGO TO
pCANNABIS INDUSTRY IN LA. FROM
ACTIVISTS THE BUSINESS OWNERS
UNDER ONE UMBRELLA TO WORK
TOGETHER TO CREATE CANNABIS
REGULATION. LICENSING AND
SOCIAL EQUITY IN THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES. WE WERE TO GET
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN THE CITY
COUNCIL IN THE PAST WITH THE
PUBLIC VOTE MARKING TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. EIGHTY POINT 4%
SUPPORT. WELL THERE'S STILL A
LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE LOS
ANGELES THERE ARE MORE
APPLICATIONS BEING PROCESSED
HERE UNDER THE SOCIAL EQUITY
PROGRAM THAN ANYWHERE ELSE IN
THE COUNTRY. WE APPRECIATE
HONORED BRADFORD CHAMPIONING OF
THESE ISSUES THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY. PARTICULARLY
THOUGHTFUL EQUITY LIKE THESE
WHO HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE CURRENT. TREES WAR ON
DRUGS. SB SIX OH THREE IS THE
HELP OUR INDUSTRY AND SOCIAL
EQUITY LICENSEES NEED TO
PROVIDE SOME RELIEF AS LEGAL
INDUSTRY INSTRUCTION IN THE
STATE. THEY'RE A LAUNDRY LIST
OF UP FRONT COSTS OF SOCIAL
EQUITY OPERATORS HAVE TINKER
BEFORE THEY CAN EVEN OPEN THEIR
DOORS FOR BUSINESS. SECURING
PROPERTY LEGAL ADVICE
APPLICATION WRITING BUILD OUT
COSTS GETTING INVENTORY. HIRING
STAFF AS WELL AS LOCAL AND
STATE LICENSING FEES. THEY ALSO
NEED TO PAY RENT ON FACILITIES
WHILE WAITING FOR APPROVAL.
MOSTLY BECAUSE YEP YOU'RE RIGHT
NOT LIKE NORMAL BUSINESS COULD
BECAUSE OF THE FEDERAL. ANTI
CANNABIS AND IN PARTICULAR TO
EIGHTY WITH THE IRS. I WOULD
ARGUE THE ASSISTANCE PROVIDED
SB SIX OH THREE WILL HELP MORE
BUSINESSES ACTUALLY GET OPEN.
START MAKING LEGAL FIELD AND
START PAYING LOCAL AND STATE
TAXES WHERE THE REBATE FROM SIX
OH THROUGH A PROVIDED THAT. IN
EACH YEAR. SB SIX OH THREE
ALLOW SOCIAL EQUITY APPLICANTS
AND LYFT. HOLDERS TO WRITE OUT
THEIR LOCAL AND STATE PLEASE
WHICH CAN BE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS IF NOT. IN THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS. SENATOR BRADFORD THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU VOTE I ON
S. B. SIX OH THREE. ALL RIGHT
THAT'S THEIR. CALL FROM TO THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. COALITION
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MISTER
OSTROM WE- YOUR TESTIMONY HERE
TO DO. LAYS IN GENERAL NOW
GOING TO GO TO A PERSON. TODAY
TO SEE IF HAVE ANYONE IN YOUR
ROOM. ONE ONE AND SEN ONE
COMES. NOT GONNA BE GOING OUR-
LINES. FOR GONNA BE CHECKING IN.
OUR MODERATOR MR MODERATOR.
LET'S CHECK IN TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANYONE IN SUPPORT IN
SUPPORT. OF SB SIX OH THREE CAN
YOU. PLEASE GIVE THOSE FOLKS UP
NOW. CERTAINLY DOES IN SUPPORT.
OF SB SIX ZERO THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW
FOR US. OUR PHONE NUMBER
TODAY'S. 877-336-4436 WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM YOU AYE
MR MODERATOR BACK TO YOU. WE
HAVE LINE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE FORTY FOUR YOU'RE
CURRENTLY IN COMMITTEE. LINE
FORTY FOUR. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER LINE CUTE IN
SUPPORT MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT
WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER MODERATOR WE
ARE NOW GOING TO BE CHECKING IN
WITH ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO NOW
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. THIS
IS SB SIX OH THREE THERE IS NO
ONE IN A ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE ARE COMMITTEE ROOM TO BE A
SPEAKING OPPOSITION SO WE DON'T
WE'RE GOING TO DO CENTER
DRESSEL MISTER VICE CHAIR WE'RE
GOING BACK TO THE PHONE LINES
THAT'S RIGHT. MISTER MODERATOR
WE'RE CHECKING IN WITH YOU ON
THE TELECONFERENCE ON THERE TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX OH THREE
CAN YOU PLEASE Q. THOSE FOLKS
UP NOW. CERTAINLY AGAIN ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX OH THREE.
ONCE AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY.
ZERO AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
ONE GIVEN IN OPPOSITION MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE HEY
MISTER MODERATOR THAT WAS OUR
LAST BILL THE DAY NICE WORKS
ARE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTNERSHIP BUT LET'S CHECK IN
WITH COMMITTEE WE HAVE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM SENATOR
ALSO PLEASE YOU HAVE BEFORE.
YES- I JUST WANT TO- BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL BUT I HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS- WHAT IS.
WHAT IS THERANGE OF THE- TAX
CREDIT- THE AMOUNT. OF THE TAX
CREDIT THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
I UNDERSTAND IT WILL BE
IDENTICAL ACROSS THE STATE BUT-
IF YOU GIVE AN IDEA OF WHAT THE
RANGES. IT HASN'T QUITE BEEN
WORKED OUT WORKING FOR SOME
ESTIMATES FROM- B. O. E. TO
HELP US. FORMULATE WHAT THOSE
COSTS WILL BE AND- WHAT THAT
RANGE WILL BE BUT- I MEAN AS
LITTLE AS FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
PRIZE MUCH IS. FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR FOLKS TO YOU KNOW
OKAY YEAH SO IT DEPENDS ON ON
ON WHAT. IT IS REALLY THE
JURISDICTION TOO LONG WHAT
THOSE FEES ARE TO. GET LICENSED
AND WHAT WE HAVE TO YOU KNOW
SYSTEM IN EITHER THE FERN HER
PROVIDE A WAY FOR TO OKAY. AND
SECOND- IF YOU COULD PROVIDE ME
WITH I'D LIKE. TO SEE IF YOU
CAN GIVE ME INFORMATION NOT
HERE BUT- ANOTHER TIME ON WHAT
THE LOCAL EQUITIES PROGRAM. IS
EITHER IN EITHER IN LA OR
SOMEWHERE WEALTHY. I JUST UP I
TRIED TO SEE WHAT IT REFERRED
TO AND MOSTLY WHAT I FOUND WAS
THAT IT. IT'S CONNECTED TO ANY
OF COMMUNITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
THAT CANNABIS CRIMINALIZATION.
OF BUT YOU ALSO MAKE REFERENCE
TO- HIGH RATES OF POVERTY AND
OTHER SO I JUST WANT TO GET
STRAIGHT. WHAT DIRECTLY YOU
KNOW WELL LET ME TELL YOU WHAT
THE INTENTION WAS BECAUSE I GET
THE BILL THE KIND OF THAT COULD
BE FILLED THREE YEARS AGO
TWELVE NINETY FOUR OR FOUR
YEARS AGO SHE SAID TWELVE
NINETY FOUR. AND THAT BILLS OF
SPECIFICALLY TO ADDRESS AGAIN
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
IMPACTED BY THE WAR ON DRUGS
AND- AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO
COMMUNITIES SPECIFICALLY AS
WELL. AND CITIES WHO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS FORTY
AVAILABLE WOULD HAVE TO STYLE
IS DIRECTLY PROGRAMS CITIES OF
LA LONG BEACH SAN FRANCISCO
OAKLAND THEY HAVE US ESTABLECER
EQUITY PROGRAMS. THE VERY- I
HATE TO BE CRITICAL OF THE CITY
OF LA BUT THEY'VE HAD SOME OF
THEIR CHALLENGES BECAUSE- WHEN
WE AS YOU MENTIONED- SPECIFIC
AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
THEY TOOK TOTAL ZIP CODES. AND
THAT THEY NARROWED DOWN SO WE
FOUND A LOT OF PEOPLE CLAIMING
TO BE FROM THOSE COMMUNITIES
OPEN UP A SHOP IN THOSE ZIP
CODES WHO NEVER WERE IMPACTED.
AND YOU KNOW THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT WERE IMPACTED WORDING
WEREN'T GETTING THE LICENSE SO
BEEN WORKING WITH CAT PACKER
WHO'S BEEN DOING A FANTASTIC
JOB IN THE CITY OF LA. WORK
THERE- EQUITY PROGRAM AND I
LIKE TO SAY LONG BEACH IS.
WORKING- THROUGH THE- J. BUT IN
SOME HAVE BEEN TAKEN OUT OF PER.
OKAY YEAH WELL ANYTHING THAT
YOU COULD NOT PROVIDE YEAH BE
GREAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER DRIVE SO- SERVICE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OFFER A
PROMOTION. WE WERE MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY CENTER DRIVE SOON
WERE ABLE IN YOU KNOW I DON'T
EVER WANT TO PUT WORDS IN THE
CENTER BRADFORD SMITH BUT I
THINK WORK IF WE COULD LAND A
PLEASE PUSH BACK ON THE ON THE
GRANT PEACE IN WHERE THE BE- WE
NEED TO BE EITHER WAY AND IS.
AN EQUAL TO THE AMOUNT OF FEES
THAT WOULD NOT BE COVERED BY A
GRANT YEAH SO I'M IN A IN THAT
MAKES PERFECT SENSE AND BECAUSE
THE CENTER BRADFORD LEADERSHIP
I KNOW THIS IS GOING TO GET
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE SO I END
HE IS TENACIOUS ON THIS ISSUE
AND GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP SIR. SO WE HAVE A
AYE MOTION ON THE FLOOR CENTER
BRADFORD B. LIKE TO CLOSE THE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE MOTION FOR BY
CENTER DRIVES- MISTER NOW CAN
YOU PLEASE PROVIDE A FORMAL
MOTION IN CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE AYE
AYES SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN
AYE SENATOR DORADO DORADO. HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER. THREE ZERO THREE SAN
VENTURA KEEP THE ROAD OPEN WERE
TO GET THE MAJORITY LEADER
INCINERATOR INTO COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
FILETS IN GERMAN I HERE'S THE
NEWS CENTER DORADO AND MR VICE
CHAIR ALL GOOD ALL GOOD- ON
EVERY DANG ROAD EXACTLY THAT'S
WHAT I'M SAYING- SO IF YOU LOOK
AT THAT TWO MINUTES BEFORE
MARTHA HOW OTHER THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ONE O'CLOCK WATCH
OUT. SO HEY EVERY GO. A VERY
GRATEFUL WE ALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE'LL SEE YOU NEXT
WEEK FOR SURE. ALL RIGHT SAFE
TRAVELS HOME Y'ALL. SO GIVE US
A YEAH EXACTLY ACTUALLY YEAH
THAT'S A CENTER WIENER TODAY
WILL BE GOOD YEAH HE HASN'T
EVEN BEEN HERE VERY VERY GO ALL
RIGHT HE'S CHEERING COMMITTEE
GIVE US ONE MINUTE- MISTER
GONNA AND I ARE GOING TO JUST
DOUBLE CHECK ON THE VOTES THAT
WE NEED TO GET. AS CENTER
HERTZBERG ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT IS IT EVER GONNA COME
ON BACK. THANKS TO MR CANAL.
ARE WE TO HEARINGS LAST APRIL
TWENTY SECOND NOT ON THE FIFTH
ON THE SIX SO WE'LL HAVE TWO
MORE HEARINGS. APRIL TWENTY
SECOND IN MAY SIXTH. UP FOR ALL
THOSE WHO ARE GOING TO BE
TUNING IN. ALL RIGHT. LET'S ADD
THE MAJORITY LEADER ON IN
CENTER WIENER IS ON HIS WAY.
LET'S START WITH ITEM NUMBER
ONE ITEM NUMBER ONE IS SB SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT BY FACTORED THE
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO
MISTER NOW. SENATOR HERTZBERG
HI. RICHBURG FIVE SENATOR
WIENER. FOR DESSERT KERN VOTED
FOUR ZERO KERN VOTED FOR AS
YOUR WHOLE THE ROLE OPEN- WELL
ITEM NUMBER TWO WAS TESTIMONY
ONLY ITEM NUMBER THREE- WE HAVE
A VOTE. RECORDED A VOTE
RECORDED BY CENTER HERTZBERG
WE'RE NOT GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. THAT'S SB THIRTY
TWO CURRENT VOTE IS TWO ONE
CHAIR VOTING ALL RIGHT MR NOW
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THE FIRST
FIVE SENATOR WIENER. THE ONE
THREE KEEP IN A ROW OPEN FOR WE
RENOWNED BE MORE. ON WE HAVE A
VOTE RECORDER TO VOTE RECORDED
ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB FORTY
FIVE FOR THE MAJORITY LEADER
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SIX. SB TWO SEVENTY
SIX CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO
MISTER GRINNELL SENATOR
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
SENATOR WIENER. FOUR ZERO FOUR
ZERO EIGHT IN GERMANY KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN S. B. TWO NINETY KERN
VOTE IS THREE ZERO THREE ZERO
MISTER NOW. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
WITH BURKE HI SENATOR WIENER.
FOUR ZERO VOTE FOR YOUR VOTE
WE'RE KEEPING THE ROLE OPEN FOR
CENTER WIENER ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
SP FOUR ONE FOUR CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE ZERO MISTER NOW
SENATOR HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
EYES SENATOR WIENER FOUR ZERO
VOTE FOR KEEPING THE ROAD OPEN
FOR CENTER WIENER AT WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO FINALS. I REMEMBER
NINE SB SIX OH THREE KERN VOTE
THREE ZERO MISTER FOR NOW
SENATOR HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG BY
SENATOR WIENER. THEY CALDERON
FOUR ZERO THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
MR MAJORITY LEADER FOUR ZERO
VOTE WE'RE KEEPING THE ROLE
OPEN FOR CENTER WINNERS AND
MICHAEL FROM THE SERGEANT'S
OFFICE IS. ON THE HUNT RIGHT
NOW. AND I WILL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU. AS SOON AS WE GET
CENTER WIENER IN COMMITTEE.
WE'LL BE BACK IN JUST A.
THE
GERMAN FOR EVAN CAN I JUST MAKE
A COMMENT ON SB FIFTY FIVE
SINCE I WASN'T HERE YES PLEASE
CENTER WIENER YES THANK YOU AND
I KNOW THAT THAT WAS JUST A
HEARING ONLY AND WILL BE MADE
IT TO YOUR BILL I JUST WANT TO
KNOW I DON'T WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR FOR PERSONAL FOR HIS WORK
ON SB TWELVE IN DEALING WITH
THESE WILDFIRE ISSUES- AND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE AUTHOR
CENTER STARTED TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH IN TERMS OF REDUCING
WILDFIRE OF PRESSURE- IN OUR-
OR DEVELOP PRESSURE IN OUR
HIGHEST RISK WILDFIRES OWNS- I
AM GLAD THIS IS BECOMING A TO
YOUR BILL BECAUSE- I THINK
TAKING A SLEDGEHAMMER APPROACH
TO SAY. YOU CAN'T EVEN BUILD AN
EIGHTY YOU OR A NEW SAID OR A
CORNER GROCERY STORE ONE OF
THESE AREAS IS PRICES GOING WAY
TOO FAR- I- I IN PARTICULAR WE
NEED TO ALWAYS MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S REDUCE PRESSURE ON
WILDFIRES OWNS THAT WE ARE
INCREASING DENSITY AND NON
WILDFIRES OWNS BECAUSE
OTHERWISE WE WILL SIMPLY MAKE
OUR HOUSING CRISIS WORSE. WORSE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE CHAIR OUR TWO COMMITTEES
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY HI
UNTIL NEXT JANUARY THANK YOU
EITHER BELIEVE IT THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIR- INTO WINNERS
BEEN CHEERING HOUSING WHICH IS
STILL GOING ON LITTLE BIT OF A
CRAZY DAY SO I APPRECIATE HIM
COMING IN AND LET'S GET RIGHT
TO IT CENTER WIENER WE HAVE
NINE ITEMS IN FRONT OF US AT
THAT START WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE
HERE WE GO SB SEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO
MISTER GONNA SENATOR WIENER ALL
RIGHT WIENER HI THAT'S FIVE
ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE CLOSER
ROLE AND SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB FIFTY FIVE.
I KNOW VOTE IS REQUIRED THAT
WITH TESTIMONY ONLY TETIMONY
ONLY HONESTY FIFTY FIVE NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER THREE
SB FOUR EIGHTY CURRENT VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO MISTER NOW. UNDER
WIENER ALL RIGHT. I FIVE ZERO
VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT RECALL
THE ROLE ITEM NUMBER FOUR. SB
THIRTY KERN VOTE IS THREE ONE
CHERUB. ON MISTER. SENATOR WE
RIGHT WIENER- FOR ONE VOTE THAT
BILL IS NOW WERE CLOSED THE
ROLE I. NUMBER IS FORTY CURRENT
IS. EIGHT ZERO MR NOW SENATOR
WIENER AYE WIENER HI FI ZERO
VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT WE'RE
CLOSING THE ROLE ITEM NUMBER
SIX. TO SEVENTY SIX CURRENT
VOTE IS FOR A ZERO MISTER
GRINNELL. THE MAJOR WIENER ALL
RIGHT WIENER HI FIVE ZERO VOTE
LAYS IN GERMAN THAT BILL IS
THAT WERE CLOSE THE ROLE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN S. B. TWO NINETY
KERN VOTE IS FOUR ZERO. MR NOW
SENATOR WIENER ALL RIGHT WE-
ARE FIVE EIGHT ZERO VOTE THAT
BILL IS THAT WERE CLOSE IN THE
ROLE HM NUMBER EIGHT AS BEFORE
ONE FOR CURRENT VOTE FOUR ZERO.
MR NOW SENATOR WIENER ALL
RIGHT- HERE ARE FIVE ZERO VOTES
THAT BILL IS THAT WERE CLOSE
THE ROLE. LAST THAT LAYS IN
GERMAN ITEM NUMBER NINE SB SIX
OH THREE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
EIGHT ZERO MISTER FOR NOW.
SENATOR WIENER. WIENER OUR FIVE
YEAR VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT TO
IN WE'RE CLOSE THE ROLE MISTER
WINNER THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'LL
SEE OVER IN HOUSING. WE WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO OUR AMAZING
TECHNICAL TEAM OF BEEN WORKING
ON THE ONES AND TWOS BEHIND AND
OF COURSE OR SERGEANTS. FOR ALL
OF THE WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE
TO DATE. MR CANAL INTO THE
ENTIRE GOVERN FI TEAM WELL DONE
IS ALWAYS WE'LL SEE YOU. NEXT
WEEK ON THE TWENTY SECOND FOR A
MONSTER OF A HEARING. HAVE A
GREAT ONE EVERYBODY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.